Thank you.
Hi, Kiki.
Hi, Melissa.
Hey, how are you doing?
Sorry, I'm eating cheese and crackers.
I just woke up from a nap and I'm trying to power some down.
I don't mean to be rude.
No worries.
I'm over here doing laundry, so you know how it is.
Good.
How are you doing?
Thanks.
Thanks for setting this up, man.
Yeah.
I mean, I hope I can answer your questions.
You know, the thing about while we're waiting for people, right?
There are a lot of really amazing astrologers, but no one really understands what it is.
I mean, I think a couple of people are sort of onto the trail, but astrology is just an analog simulation model, right?
So it was developed, there are people who say, oh, it's 12,000.
No, it's not.
It was developed in Babylon.
There was a 500-year sort of experiment that they called ordinary watching, where the scribes in the priestly classes recorded all the astronomical events and all the events on the planet that they're aware of.
You know, with royalty, the aristocratic classes, foreign relations, et cetera, and developed a system of correlations between them.
So in essence, it was their attempt to do what we would look at as like the whole world simulation that they run in Indiana, right?
We used digital technology to run these simulations, and they did not.
So that would be the big difference, but theirs is based on, or astrology is based on a much larger data set, even than the whole world simulation, right?
So astrology is as big as the universe.
It's as big as reality, because that's what it is.
It's a model of reality.
So there are people who have vast knowledge of the technical aspects of astrology.
Chris Brennan, I think.
I can't think of anyone on Earth who has a more comprehensive understanding of every possible aspect of astrology than Chris Brennan.
Now, his record as a predictive astrologer, in my opinion, is not very good.
And one might argue that the two really, you know, they're at odds, right?
Like, so he has a perseverative interest in details about astrology as opposed to the utilization of astrology for prediction.
And because of that, I'm not trying to trash him, I'm just trying to, this is a sort of a preface, right?
He never really developed the, or it seems that he never really spent much time working through cognitive biases and developing sort of working on how to think as opposed to what to think.
So there are technical astrologers, which is sort of where we all start out, but astrology itself is an academic discipline.
And so it's really about learning how to know, right?
In the context, any academic discipline is about learning how to know.
If you're a zoologist, you don't learn everything about zoology, but you learn, you know, how to learn what you need to know to study a new animal or a set of behaviors amongst animals, research and experimentation and what sources, et cetera.
So with astrology, the same thing is true.
And generally speaking, I'm not saying this is going to happen with you guys, but someone might show up.
Generally speaking, once you start talking about astrology in this type of conversation, you have someone show up.
And this is, this was my experience last year where I had someone show up and someone who sort of information minds and has a very particular interest.
And they'll show up and they'll test you or test me in this case, or the individual that they're talking to.
They'll test them with like, you know, to see how much they know about this one particular thing.
And what happened last year was I had this guy show up and he just started grilling me about a, a book written in German in like 1875.
It was in the 1870s.
And I had no idea what he was talking about.
Right.
And it took me like several conversations with him after the space to figure out like where he was coming from.
The book was entitled scientific astrology.
He keyed into the term scientific astrology and didn't really know anything about astrology in general.
Started from that one particular individual's work or a rough translation of it and built this whole sort of model of what astrology should be.
So, um, I think your questions are pretty easy, but people might have a complicated question and that is something like it may not be my particular interest.
Right.
So not knowing in advance, if you have like, uh, an astrological consultation, originally, if we were going back to like the eighties and nineties, um, you, uh, an astrologer work about six hours to prepare for a session, um, uh, with a client.
So now computers have like shortened that, but what has happened is as the focus has gone to like the technical, um, astrology, right.
Um, like a limited set of, of answers that people could memorize.
You get a lot, a lot of like very young astrologers who will memorize like a couple of books and, um, then they go into their readings cold.
Right.
And they usually look like models for some reason that became this thing where, um, people on Tik TOK will pay to like get astrology readings from models.
I don't know what's sort of an odd thing, but it happened.
And, um, so they'll go, they'll go into the readings cold.
I, I would spend, if I was working with someone about three hours, um, probably prior to every conversation that we had.
And because the detail, when you're young and you can memorize everything, right.
That's if you have that type of mind, but very few of us can do it as we get older.
And the details are very, very important.
So if you were to ask me a question about your natal chart, like I would want to sit and look at it.
And if I questioned anything I remembered, I would look up the details again, uh, and write everything down and prepare because even a slip of the tongue or a misremembering or anything like that, right.
Could have ethical consequences.
Um, it is why it's important you have your exact birth time.
If you ever get your chart done, because five minutes can change something important about the reading.
And it's really unethical for someone to give you that reading if they don't have the exact time, because you can go forward with this set of beliefs, right.
Uh, based on it, some people don't take it that seriously.
Some people do.
Um, so I think I got the gist of both of your questions, but if you like, have like an obscure book or something, I probably would have to look into that before I can answer the questions.
Um, hey, Sal.
Cool.
Uh, Melissa.
Um, Sarah Height.
Uh, and it's, what is it?
Dame.
Uh, I always forget.
See, uh, Demonic.
Uh, she is an astrologer, actually.
No, but I think she's a tantric astrologer.
Again, there's a number of different, um, people innovate, right.
So we run into that definitely on X with, um, astrologers, remote viewers, um, anything that's not sort of a, it's a, maybe an academic discipline, but not a hard academic discipline, right.
And so people will kind of come up with their own niche.
And then in order to, you know, make money, they'll, they'll engage in hostile marketing where they'll, and you've, you've seen it with something, right.
It may not be astrology.
It could be like vitamins or something.
Well, they'll come out and be like, doctors don't want you to know about, you know, they want you to have medicine.
And, you know, what you should really be doing is taking this herb that no one knows what it's doing to your liver, right?
Like, um, you know, you have to start by attacking, um, the opponent.
So we get that a lot with the astrology where people, and I'm not saying she's doing this, but, uh, you'll find people sort of, um, undermining, uh, everyone else, what they're doing and developing their own innovations.
So I can only say like, I guess, or I think, um, when I talk about other astrologists, cause I don't have time to, um, like get involved in memorizing what people are doing and try to undermining them or whatever.
They can do their own thing.
Um, okay.
So, uh, that was the preface.
Um, so I think I first got the, so Kiki, you have a list.
I'm going to let you know right off the top that, um, the transits of inner planets through the signs are something I don't really pay, um, too much attention to.
That was, um, when astrology was being developed, they didn't know about the outer planets.
And so they didn't have an exact, like, they didn't really know why sometimes interplanet transits seem to have, like, really momentous effects on people's lives.
But other times they, they didn't.
So they developed entire systems to kind of explain why at a certain time a planet would be more effective for a certain individual or in certain signs.
So what was really going on as far to my, to the best of my knowledge, um, were, was that they were seeing the effects of inner planets triggering or activating outer planet transits.
Right.
So what can happen sometimes is let's say you have a transit of, um, Uranus.
Well, Uranus is pretty good.
Uranus is pretty exact, but let's say you have a transit of Uranus to your sun.
The day that transit is exact, you may not have, uh, an event specifically, but then a month or two later, when Mars comes along, Jupiter, Mars, uh, the moon, particularly an eclipse, will, uh, fall on that degree.
And then you will have the, um, the outer planet transit.
They didn't know that in the past.
Um, but we can look back now and it's pretty clear that that was what, oh God, sorry.
Um, that that was what was going on.
I don't know why my cat is screeching for some reason.
So if you hear that in the background, I don't have no idea why she's fine.
She's eaten and everything.
I don't know.
I think she wants to eat again.
Um, yeah.
So, uh, yeah, there's an, there's an effect, right?
Like, um, uh, with Taurus specifically right now in, in this period of time, like, um, most everything that's been going on with Taurus for the last seven years reflects Uranus's presence in the sign.
Um, so when I was coming up, um, what, you know, we were told or what people would say was, uh, cause I don't want to upset anyone with this, like a value judgment, um, that Uranus and Taurus represented fascism.
Um, historically, I would amend that because fascism is a loaded term, right?
We get into the exact details of, uh, Hey, uh, bark like a duck.
How you doing, man?
Hey, science.
Listen, sometimes I can't read these names.
Glyph.
Glymph.
I'm sorry if I'm getting that messed up.
Well, hello.
Um, so I would say, uh, right-wing populism would be a, a better way, like, would be a, a, a less offensive, um, term to everyone involved.
Uh, but when Uranus transits Taurus, that's when you see the behaviors in society that we associate, uh, with right-wing populism.
And, of course, X is like the universal hub of right-wing populism, right?
During this period of time.
So we all see it every day.
And I'm not, if, if that's your vibe, that's great.
I am non-political.
Uh, and I don't believe that people who are involved in any type of forecasting or prediction should be involved in politics in, in any, in any form, because, uh, the cognitive, um, bias that's involved is going to affect people's readings.
And it's why, um, oftentimes the majority of astrologers at any given time are wrong about things like predicting elections, right?
Uh, it shouldn't be possible for that to happen.
Uh, but it does happen because cognitive bias, um, affects everyone.
Uh, so you gotta limit, um, what you get involved in and what you invest your, your time and energy in.
Um, so I, I excelled politics a long time ago.
Um, so the, specifically, uh, Venus's transit through Taurus at this time, I would look at it as far as like from a Monday in a world effect.
Like I would, uh, it probably manifest in, in some sort of set of, uh, memes or talking.
Points involving, um, the themes of Taurus related to right-wing stuff.
So we look at like MAGA, uh, we look at the administration, um, look at, uh, people who are like, um, uh, trad wives.
Is that, I don't think that's the, the term, uh, trad wives.
Like it's, um, it's interesting cause it's like back to the land, right?
But back to the land was like a hippie thing.
Um, in my parents' time.
And now what's like, um, it's a right-wing populist position.
So aesthetic, right?
Aesthetically.
So I would look at like, um, sort of peripheral trends on Instagram will probably be affected.
Or YouTube, uh, posts on X will probably be affected.
Um, perhaps there'll be something involving, um, the, the trad wife aesthetic in advertising during that period.
And maybe there'll be a commercial that you'll see, um, that will have, um, something to do with that aesthetic.
That's the type of effect, um, that one would look for when Venus goes through a sign, um, unless it affects your natal chart, right?
Even then, the, um, the importance or the notability of inner planet transits was significantly, uh, overestimated in the past for the reasons that I mentioned earlier.
Cause they just didn't know, um, about the outer planets and weren't able to discern when the notable event was related to an outer planet transit.
And, you know, uh, being activated by an inner planet.
Um, yeah, so unless it affects your like specific, some, um, like specific effect to your natal chart, like I don't, it's just going to be an aesthetic, right?
I mean, in my case, uh, I do have like a Taurus, I'm a Taurus moon.
Yeah.
Um, so you look at the house, right?
Um, moon is, uh, inner motivations mostly.
Um, yeah.
Um, and look at the house that's affected and that's the area that it will, um, it will show up in.
Right.
So then you go sign house transit.
So Taurus is the backdrop, um, but it would affect, it would have a, a, where that aesthetic enhancement would show up would vary, um, between you and I, or, um, you and Shane based on which house.
Uh, so for instance, um, um, I have a son in the 12th house.
Uh, so for, um, um, most people, uh, hospitals aren't, um, aren't something that, that factors, um, a lot in the hospitals, jails, um, environments like that monasteries.
It's not a big factor in, in most people's lives.
Whereas, you know, for me, um, when I have, uh, uh, transit to my, uh, Capcom, right.
Uh, when I have a transit to Capcom and other people experience differently, um, it will, um, it will show up in, in the environment related to like medicine or, uh, or jails.
Something for me because of my medical issues almost, um, entirely at this point in my life, those backdrop, um, environmental transits, uh, play out in the, in the experiences I have when I go to the hospital, when I go to the physical therapist or whatever.
Um, so I would look for your house, uh, the house that's involved and that's the area of your life.
There'd be like, um, maybe a bit of a glow, a glow up.
Is that what they say?
Like you may have a bit of a glow up in that, in that environment or, um, it could be emotional.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, God damn it.
I'm sorry.
I'm having cat issues as always, as always, because somewhere along the line, I became a dormant.
And for cats and now I put it in with that.
Okay.
I have to escort this gentleman out of my room where I, it would be nice to have an office, but the cats have the office.
All right.
Now it's just us.
All the cats are out.
Um, yeah, I, I wouldn't expect much from it.
So the, the thing with that is right, like cognitive bias is a huge problem in astrology.
And so if you focus on it enough, you're going to see something that, um, matches your expectations.
Um, but I've never had anyone have something life-changing related to, um, related to like Venus in, in, um, Venus in Taurus.
So, okay.
So, but the way this is going to work out, right.
Is you go look at your chart.
And so the moon rules cancer.
So you look at your chart and you look at the houses involved, right.
And you look at the house that, uh, has cancer at the, at the cusp, at the beginning of the house.
Um, so for me, that's the six house.
So when something activates my moon, right.
I have, um, an event related to the six house.
So it's complicated because it's complicated for something so small, right.
It was this, this is, um, important stuff if you're analyzing and out of planet transit, but
the way it works is there will be an event in the, um, the house that the planet is transiting.
So, um, if it was your first house and you have a planet transiting your first house, you
may have an event related to your body or your appearance, right.
Or make mostly your body or your parents is mostly how, what it's going to relate to.
Okay.
And then we interpret that based on the type of transit it is.
So moon, sun, whatever.
And then we look at the house that begins with, or, you know, um, in this case, cancer on the
cusp and the result will occur there.
Honestly, it's way too complicated because you're only going to see something related to
a Venus transit like that.
If you're looking for it, if you're experiencing extreme, um, trauma.
Um, extreme cognitive bias.
Um, however, if you had like, um, a Uranus or Pluto transit, that would be something that
you would see a lot more.
Um, so by analogy, because I can't, I can't give you an analogy of like, uh, Venus going
through Taurus.
Um, but I can tell you like, this is how I became convinced of, um, I studied astrology,
but I have a number of, uh, uh, I studied, um, comparative eschatology.
I studied a long wave economic cycles.
Like astrology was just one, um, of a, of a number of, um, of things I spent time studying
when I was younger.
Uh, but what made me commit specifically to interpreting everything through that framework,
uh, was, um, a Uranus transit, uh, square my natal son, which is, uh, a death transit.
Uh, it's not a death transit for everyone.
It depends on how it falls in your chart.
It is a death transit for someone in your life.
Um, but it can be a peripheral figure, right?
It could be a doctor or it could be a boss, or it could be in this case, uh, like I said,
my son is in the, um, 12th house and, um, it, it ended up being, uh, exact one hour, um,
one hour from the Boston marathon.
And, uh, we were just sort of this crazy sequence of events.
Um, one of the perpetrators of the Boston marathon was someone I had had a, the older
Sarnief brother, this won't mean anything to you if you're not from Massachusetts, was
someone I had had an encounter with, uh, a, uh, uh, not a violent encounter, but a hostile
encounter.
And the individuals or some of the individuals who were most prominently affected, um, at
the, the finish line of the marathon, they had some limbs blown off or whatever, were enemies
of mine.
There were people I grew up with that I would have defined as, um, as an enemy.
So, um, it, it wound up being like exactly within an hour that, you know, they, they, the,
they set off the bombs and people died and, uh, both, uh, public enemies of mine and, and
private enemies of mine ended up dying because of that, uh, situation.
So, um, so like in that case, like, you know, um, uh, Uranus was in Aries, right?
So that's, uh, explosive violence would fall into that, uh, set of, of possibilities.
So in that case, it's very important to go through the whole thing of, uh, what sign is the planet
in, um, what planet is the, is, is that planet aspecting and where the rulership is.
It's, it's not with Venus.
Um, what was the next question was, uh, um, I'm sorry.
I'm trying to look at this.
You had a number of questions.
You had a Venus.
Okay.
Full moon Libra.
Yeah.
Um, I'm not a moon person either.
Like, I, I really think it's going to be a very small, um, thing.
Uh, the most notable lunar events that I've, full moons or, um, or new moons, right?
Um, unless they aspect an outer planet transit or they, they activate a, um, an eclipse, um,
unless they're an eclipse or they activate an eclipse or they activate an outer planet transit,
they're like, maybe you'll hear from someone you haven't heard from in a long time.
It was like that level of, so again, I would have to know what house, right?
It falls in, um, because it's, it's sign, right?
And then house.
And so it would vary depending on which of the 12 houses you had there, but the outcome
would be of the level like of importance.
I would say a two or three, um, where somebody you hadn't talked to in a long time.
contacted you, or, uh, you had a important conversation with your mother or like something
like that.
Um, it, that in itself is, is not ever going to indicate a life-changing event, but if it
does, it's because it's, it's activating out of planet transit or an eclipse.
So that would not be, um, that would not be this month, but next, or that would not be
April, but may, uh, the full moon will square the eclipse.
And so that's when you look for big events.
So you go, you take an eclipse, uh, you look at it when the moon squares, the eclipse, um,
Oh, sorry.
The sun squares the eclipse or the, um, the sun is opposite.
So it's, uh, you start by saying like, okay, we're going to look 90 days, give or take a few
days in advance of the date of an eclipse.
Then we'll look at 180 days, give a few days.
And then you look at Mars and Jupiter and, and see how they, um, interact with the eclipse.
Like what day does, uh, Mars cross that degree and you get a set of dates, uh, three or four,
maybe you would isolate that you might have a notable event related to, or that you would
associate with, um, a full moon or, uh, a new moon, but otherwise really you're only going
to notice like very subtle stuff.
Um, unless it's an eclipse, an eclipse can be a life-changing event.
Um, depending on how it interacts with your natal charts, like if you have an eclipse to your
ascendant, um, or your MC, uh, that's going to be one of the most notable years of your
life, right?
Um, if, if it's conjunct your sun, that's, that's a super, that's going to be, you know,
one of the most notable years of your life, but I would have to see your chart or you would
have to see your chart in order to ascertain if that's the case.
And for most people, it's not going to be the case.
Um, if it is the case, uh, for you, go ahead.
Go ahead.
Yeah.
Well, I guess I should, should clarify because I haven't really studied my houses, but like
part of the reason why I've asked these particular questions is because, um, I am a, I'm a Libra
sun, my Taurus moon, and my Mars is retrograde in Aries.
And so those, um, particular transits, uh, stuck out at me.
And then my Gemini, uh, what is it?
Midheaven and, and, uh, there's something else with, uh, with Gemini, but I haven't looked
at the houses, but that kind of was what stuck out at me.
I see what, so, so what really is, is calling to you specifically right now is that there's
a correlation between a number of, uh, natal chart positions and events that are happening
in the, yeah.
Okay.
So the thing about this is, first of all, everyone is going to have a big, uh, April this year.
I mean, right now, like we're living through historically momentous events and those events
are going to get like far more intense.
So if you can ask me like, are, is something intense going to happen about you?
Absolutely.
Something intense is going to happen in your life.
It just so happens.
It's one of those times it's going to happen in everyone's.
If you ask me like, how will it happen in your life?
I would have to see the houses involved.
Right.
Um, because it, it plays out in different areas for different people.
Uh, some people are affected in, in work.
Some people are affected in, in their home life or with their parents or with their possessions.
But I definitely, this is a, apropos to Shane's question.
So we can touch back on that because, uh, Shane wants to know how the outer planet transits
affect, um, affect, uh, our natal charts.
And that would be more, uh, apropos Mars entering Aries is big.
Um, do you have, is it in the early degrees of Aries?
Do you have an idea of, is it, is it towards the beginning of the sign?
Uh, I have to look.
Okay.
So the reason is like, that's big right now, uh, because we had the conjunction of Saturn
and Neptune, and that is as far as synodic conjunctions, um, things that happen in the
sky unrelated to our natal charts, but that sort of shape the narrative of history.
That is the, the biggest or the most important, I don't fucking trying to think of the right
word, most notable, um, it's five degrees.
Oh, five degrees.
Yeah.
You have a big fucking year.
Um, in August, uh, August and, and the beginning of next year as well.
Um, uh, so, uh, right now though, right.
What, what's going to happen in, in April is related to, or at least in the beginning
of April is related to the, uh, February 20th.
Conjunction of Saturn and Neptune.
And the reason is Mars is going to cross that point, zero degrees Aries.
And it's going to do that on the 10th of April, like could be the night of the 9th morning of
the 10th.
But when that happens, that's going to activate the, the most notable, um, uh, planetary conjunction
of our lifetimes, if not for hundreds of years.
Um, and I think this should be evident to everyone from just looking at the news, right?
So we made a number of spaces about this last year.
And actually, this is why I got back into, uh, posting on X.
Um, I hadn't really done anything with my X account for years.
I got back into it in 2023 to try to talk to people about this.
Um, and I started focusing on astrologers.
I originally switched my handle to the last astrologer because it was part of a, uh, a project.
And, um, anyhow, uh, basically I was, I was trying to have conversations with astrologers,
um, without sending people emails because we used to talk via email.
But then, um, because there are kind of a lot of cranky people, um, a lot of astrologers and
other people, promote viewers and all kinds of, you know, YouTube, um, vloggers, right?
People make their email, uh, inaccessible now because they don't want to get, um, disturbing,
unusual or repetitive messages from people.
So, um, even though I could, I could talk for hours with someone, um, with another astrologer,
right?
Like, uh, if, if something is important, um, I might not be able to get in touch with them.
Like I once, once we, we all could get in touch with each other because originally all
of our emails were public, right?
Um, so I got involved with X for that, to talk to them about, you know, why is no one talking
about this because this is a, uh, very notable and, um, so we made, we did those spaces and
we're trying to warn people about the escalation of the war, about the oil crisis, about the
economic crisis.
And what, and I'll get back to, I'm just going to circle back, but this is important because
it connects to Shane's question.
And it connects to like sort of the answer to your question about what to expect next
month, uh, zero degrees Aries is the, is the world point is the ascendant.
It's the, um, the, of, of, of reality of the, of the planet of earth.
And that's the, the point in your chart that represents like your manifestation in the physical
plane, right?
Like I said, it's, it's your parents, it's your body.
Um.
Um, for, for the planet, like for the, the, the chart of reality, which is what the horoscope
really is.
Right.
Um, when something happens at zero degrees Aries, an outer planet, an outer planet conjunction,
uh, that is going to be the most important, uh, event, um, until there is another, uh, important
outer planet conjunction at that point, which could be hundreds of years.
So, uh, history can be shaped for hundreds of years by one of these, um, uh, by, uh, a cyanotic
conjunction at that point.
And, uh, Saturn and Neptune, uh, often represents the fall of a civilization or the end of a form
of civilization.
So, um, and it actually connects with a lot of, like it connects with Russia.
Oftentimes, um, it's a very important, um, transit to Russia.
Things, important things involving Russia always happen.
Um, and when the Saturn and, um, Neptune, when the conjunction falls in Aries, uh, it often
involves, um, a war with Russia, with someone else, with another civilization, but Neptune
rules, uh, oil.
Uh, it, it rules oil.
It rules, um, you know, the ocean.
It rules, uh, the collective unconscious.
Um, it rules earthquakes, uh, volcanoes, right?
Um, climate change, uh, things like that are all in the sort of the purview of Neptune.
And in order having this, it can rule pandemics as well.
That's, I, I mentioned this in a space a couple of weeks ago that certain types of pandemics
could be indicated.
And I got very concerned when the meningitis thing started because meningitis is swelling
on the brain and Neptune rules swelling.
Um, so it basically means like the end of industrial civilization is, is one possible, um, is one
possible interpretation of the transit of, um, Saturn and Neptune at, uh, zero degrees Aries.
Um, and so it was very important and I, I did what I could.
It's the reason we did all those spaces, um, all the spaces that we've done so far.
Um, not everything directly addressed that one particular or this one particular period of
time, but everything was related to it.
Information necessary to understand one or more aspects of what we're experiencing right now.
Um, so, uh, last year, last summer, we saw the foreshadowing.
We saw a series of events that, um, would indicate what was going to occur during this period of
time.
What we would predict was that these events would become very serious immediately following
the conjunction on February 20th.
That's what we did predict.
Um, and, um, when to give you an example in 2020, when Saturn and Pluto had their conjunction,
it was on the 11th of January and on the 12th of January, uh, that's when the pandemic made
the news originally, but it takes a certain number of months, right?
Like it took, uh, two and a half months, uh, for the pandemic to sort of spread everywhere.
Um, not necessarily infection wise, but as far as the effect it had on society, sort of spread
around the world in that period of time.
Um, in this particular case, because of Mars being a planet that tends to activate longer
term outer planet transits, we're able to predict not just when these issues were going
to become serious, but when the.
Um, when the next step occurs, like when, right.
So we have foreshadowing, then we have things that are going to get serious, the rising action.
And then it's like the climactic period of time, um, would occur when Mars crosses that
or would begin when Mars crosses that, um, that point zero degrees.
There is now that's going to be the ninth or 10th of April.
So what we look at is around February 20th.
Following that, um, we would begin seeing the, um, the situations, the events that are going
to relate to this, uh, collapse of industrial civilization.
Now that doesn't happen immediately.
Right.
So this is like, um, a transit where you're looking at two or three years as things play
out.
And then over time, right.
Um, over a 36 year period, you sort of see like everything working out historically events
in history don't happen in just two years.
Right.
They have like, uh, like Rome fell on a certain day, but it was really like, uh, an event that
took decades and then, you know, things take decades and all of a sudden it's one day and
something happens.
So that's, what's going to happen in, in April.
So April we've been looking at for years and, um, we have, uh, some specific concerns.
Now the, we is now me, uh, because everyone else bailed out.
So I'm saying we, because we ran those spaces now it's just me.
I'm not speaking in like a rural, a royal tense, uh, what you've seen the, um, the oil
stuff, right.
Begin to, um, begin to happen immediately.
Um, the, do you feel any, do you feel, yeah.
Do you feel any particular way about the month of July?
Yeah, yes, absolutely.
So July is when, um, when Mars is going to activate the, the transit of Uranus into, uh,
Gemini, right.
So Uranus goes into Gemini, uh, on the 25th of April, but Mars won't cross that degree,
um, until, and enter, uh, Gemini until like the 30th of, uh, June.
And so the first few days of July are going to be the days when we see the events related
to, um, uh, Uranus in, um, sorry, like I said, I just woke up from a nap and as everyone
knows, I'm, I'm, I'm kind of scatterbrained.
Um, anyone who's listened to my spaces, I should say Uranus in Gemini.
So, uh, Uranus in Gemini is bifurcation.
Um, Uranus in Taurus, like I said, is right-wing populism.
Uranus in Gemini is bifurcation.
That's like, um, the period where society divides starkly along two lines, usually leading
to conflict.
So, um, this occurred during the American revolution, which was also a world war.
Um, so, uh, France and the UK were duking it out all over the place and their allies were
as well.
We just, we remember it as the American revolution though, right?
But there was a global division as well as a division in the U S, uh, between the Tories
and the revolutionaries, um, the civil war, uh, same thing happened.
Um, it wasn't as much of a global war, but certainly there were other parties involved.
Uh, you know, the Russians sent, uh, the Navy to assist us, uh, the, um, the English were
going to go in on the side of the Confederacy, um, but the, the Russians intimidated them enough
that they didn't do this, didn't do so.
Uh, so that was a division globally and a division here in the U S and, um, and then
world war two, uh, that would be the next time.
Uh, so you see less of a division inside the U S or at least history doesn't record it.
Um, but a, a global, a stark global division.
Um, there was Germany and, and France, right.
And then, you know, Russia was on Germany's side.
Then right in that period of time, uh, Russia and Germany had a falling out and everyone sort
of had to pick one side.
And so it went from being like sort of two vague groups to being like two starkly divided
poles.
Um, that's what happens when Uranus enters, um, Gemini and we're going to, again, the same
way that it worked out with, um, with Saturn, Neptune, what we're going to see is, uh, sort
of the beginnings, right?
So in late April, you'll see the beginning of the formalization, uh, or events, sort of
crisis events leading to the formalization of this division.
But in July, that's when it's, it's going to happen.
Um, there'll be some large event or some very notable event, which will, um, which will lead
to a, a sort of stark division both inside the U S and outside of the U S.
It's not, it didn't happen last time inside the U S, but it's going to happen this time.
We all know that.
Right.
So when you look at like, and I hate to say this cause I'm not, I don't wish for it at
all, but if you look for like a beginning of sectarian conflict in the U S, that's when
you would look for it in July.
I'm trying to look at your list.
Um, yeah, so that's what Mars entering areas would be.
And that's what, uh, Mars entering Gemini in July would tend to indicate, um, as well.
Is that your birthday?
Is that what you're trying to tell me?
Kiki?
No, my birthday is in September.
Okay.
It would be specifically notable if your birthday was in early July.
Go ahead, Shane.
Hey JT.
Um, what's that mean?
So, you know, what you were just saying there was, is a question I had written down for
you.
If, if you look back at each war that has happened in history and let's say you didn't have a
knowledge of those events, like of the American revolution, the civil war, world war one, could
you look back and see in the charts and expect that something might've happened?
I guess that's what you were just saying, right?
And, and then you can look that, look forward and see something similar may be happening
in July.
So history is the right history.
What we, the narrative of history is the result of the interaction of the outer planets.
So we can start by tracing it.
Obviously we can look back at civilization going back thousands of years.
Right.
But the big events in civilization from our perspective started around 600 BC.
And from an astrological perspective, they started in, I'm going to fuck this up, but I think
it's 578 BC, which is the, um, triple axial conjunction.
So it was a period of like two and a half years where all three outer planets, um, were loosely
in conjunction with each other.
Right.
So it's like, that's the starting line.
And then as time goes on from that, from that point forward, right.
You can almost look at, see them as like tracing out a shape of, of a series of interactions.
And these cycles govern, uh, uh, wars and changes in culture and rises in civilization and art
and science and, um, and it really depends on which two planets you're talking about, what
that synodic cycle, the conjunction, and then, um, the relationship as they go around the
sun, uh, rules.
As far as wars are concerned, uh, well, so confirmation bias can get involved here, right?
Cause there's always a war.
Um, this is always a war.
So you're always going to see wars when you look back, but yeah, like the same type of character
of events, politically speaking, the same type of, um, social events and the same type of
conflicts.
So to get specific to your point, uh, going down the line right now, um, a couple of years
ago, Pluto entered Aquarius and, uh, Pluto and Aquarius, um, no one is going to, okay.
Everyone is going to tell you this isn't true, but it is, uh, Aquarius was redefined in the
sixties, uh, for political and ideological reasons, not formally, but sort of, um,
just everyone's conception of what Aquarius was or is, uh, Aquarius, uh, historically represented
a priest.
And so, um, when Pluto, when we look back at those periods, we see periods of, um, conflict,
uh, related sort of inter-religious conflict, um, Christian schisms and fighting between different
Christian religions or, because it's the same religions, Christian sex and different Christian
cultures.
Um, Aries, Neptune and Aries is, uh, crusades.
And, um, so if you look back, you would see periods of crusading, not necessarily, uh, against
other Christian sex, it could be Christian sex against other, other cultures or other religions.
Uh, uh, last time it occurred, the civil war was the big event in the U.S.
People, it's so complicated, it's so complicated to talk about history because there's so much
that people don't know, not, not saying you don't, but I'm just in general.
Um, so, um, the civil war was about slavery.
It was about states' rights, uh, alien protocols.
I will, uh, I'm going to try to, I'm going to try to do this.
Well, I can't multitask.
So, uh, uh, I think you're approved, buddy.
Okay, so it was about slavery.
It was about states' rights.
But the, what tied those together, um, I'm not going to digress too much, but just to explain
what tied those together was the feudalists, the feudal lords from England settled in the
South and they built the estates.
So when we look back at slave plantations, what people don't understand is the families
that owned this land plate, slave plantations were aristocratic families from England.
They didn't just show up off a boat like regular schmoes and start building slave plantations.
They were feudal.
They were like the younger members of feudal families who came here and rebuilt feudal estates,
but they, they didn't have peasants.
And that's where the slave trade to the U S became a thing.
They replaced the peasantry.
With slaves in the North, it was populated by the people from, um, uh, East Anglia, the,
the Puritans, right?
Who were anti-slavery, who were abolitionist, but they were anti-monarchy.
So an anti-feudalist.
So the battle itself, the civil war itself included slavery is a, is a, is a incredibly important
included states' rights, incredibly important, but it was really fought over.
Feudalism, but feudalism has a theological basis.
So the, the, uh, Episcopalians and the Anglicans of the South at that time, right?
It was before evangelism and everything, right?
We're, we're pro, a theologically pro-monarchy and theologically pro-aristocracy.
And the North was governed by Puritans and the churches that had split off from the Puritans
who were theologically against aristocracy.
So it was a holy war.
The civil war was a holy war.
Um, it was a crusade, right?
But it was a crusade on both sides against each other, right?
So the South was crusading.
The North was crusading, uh, buddy, I'm sorry.
I thought, I thought I let you up.
I don't know if you chose not to come up or, um, you don't have to speak, but I, I thought
I, you know, I'm not too good technically.
Okay.
So, um, yeah, so, uh, Neptune and Aries is a, is a, is a crusade.
Um, Neptune represents, uh, religion.
Um, it represents the collective unconscious.
And so it's like inspiration.
It's a type of crusade where like inspiration, um, leads to, uh, aggressions.
I don't, I don't know if Joan of Arc was tied into this, but it's like that type of vibe,
right?
So I'm not saying she was, but I'm saying like, it's that type of like crusade with like
a divine leader type situation.
And, um, Uranus in, uh, Gemini is bifurcation.
It doesn't always lead to civil wars and sectarian conflicts, but it usually does.
So, yeah, those are the three types of conflict that you would look for with the outer planet,
um, placements that we have right now.
Right now they're all tied together.
The reason that people can't see this is because, um, um, we know the South is very religious,
but we still sort of have a view of America as being, um, what's the word I'm looking for?
Um, you know, as being, uh, you know, as being, uh, non-religious secular, right?
We're not, um, the North, if you were, if you live in New England and we, we did a space
about this last year, if you live in New England, if you live in the coastal areas, uh, most likely
you believe you're not religious, um, you definitely believe you're less religious than everyone else.
But the truth is the, the, um, North of New England, the American coastal culture is probably the most
fundamental religious sect on earth.
It's so fundamental that, um, that everyone who accepts it believes it's self-evident and they're
not religious at all.
And it comes from ultra-Calvinism.
Uh, the Puritans of Massachusetts, um, ran the, uh, Ivy League schools and which were originally
seminaries.
And so, you know, for 200 years, everyone who graduated from Harvard, uh, or Yale, whatever
there's, they were a, they were priest, right?
Or they were trained for the ministry, um, in, in, even if they didn't practice.
Uh, so regardless of, of whether someone has a, uh, a God figure, the, the political movement
associated with the North has a religious character and is absolutely involved in these crusades, right?
That's what the revolution was.
The revolution, the civil war and world war two were crusades for the modern descendants
of Puritans.
And that's how it's lining up right now, right?
It's, it's lining up.
Like when you look at red versus blue in this country, you're looking at the culture war.
And when you look at the culture war, you're looking at theology, Baptists and evangelicals,
in the South and secularists who are really modern Puritans on the coasts and in New England.
So that's, that's the type of war that's coming.
I mean, I hope I look, I would prefer that it were resolved without violence.
Right.
Um, but realistically, that's what astrology predicts.
And it always has, um, people were writing articles about this in the nineties, they're not online
because a lot of stuff wasn't online, but with, for this time period specifically, um, and you're
probably familiar with like generation theory, which is outside of astrology, right?
Strauss and how predicted the same thing, um, in the nineties, they were writing about it
for this period of time.
So, uh, it's an intersection with the global situation.
Uh, the global situation, uh, specifically, um, whenever Saturn and Neptune have a conjunction
in Aries, Russia fights a war with somebody.
And, uh, up until this point, they've won when Saturn and Neptune are, are in Aries, sometimes
they make conjunctions and all the signs, those always have some sort of notable effect on
the Russian people, the Russian state.
It's not always a positive one.
Uh, it's not, it was never positive, right?
But it's, it's not a victory in war, generally speaking, it, it, it is historically when Saturn and
Neptune make a conjunction in the sign of Aries, um, because it's at the world point, which is,
hasn't happened since, uh, 43, 60 BC.
Um, we can only speculate and this is kind of a loaded topic because Russia isn't like when
I was growing up, you could talk about Russia in certain contexts without upsetting people.
But now we're a divided country and there's a large portion of our population who's
very pro-Russian.
Now it's, it's just sort of like something that everyone accepts now.
So I'm going to sound like a boomer, uh, by saying, oh, that's so weird.
But it is weird to, to someone who, you know, I mean, I grew up in, uh, um, I'm 51 years
old.
So, um, you know, I remember a time when the idea that a third of the American population
would be highly pro-Russian was crazy.
You wouldn't, you wouldn't believe it if anyone told you that.
Uh, but I don't want to, uh, I don't want to trigger anyone.
Um, you know, their political beliefs, uh, as you approach a global conflict, there is a
lot of stuff that happens behind the scenes and it happens with all of the nations involved.
So we all know there have been a tremendous number of mysterious fires and explosions going
back to the beginning of COVID, um, in American farms and factories, fossil fuels, railroads,
bridges.
What most people don't realize is the same thing has also happened in Russia and to a lesser
degree in China.
Now, no one here, at least as far as I know, has personal direct evidence.
Um, but this has always been something that occurs pre-war sabotage is something that happens.
It happened before world war two, it happened before world war one, it happened before the
civil war.
It's just part of the lead up to a major war.
So in that context, without making a value judgment to offend anyone's politics, uh, the
events surrounding, I even need to say like, well, Iran isn't, Iran is, um,
well, it's not a client state.
We know that now, right?
Iran is in, is in, is an allied state to the Russians.
Although the Russians didn't really come through for them this time, but they, they have been
historically allied states, right?
But if we go back to the beginning of this, what's happening?
And again, I don't want to affect, if anyone's, if anyone's politics, I'm just telling you
the best of my understanding, uh, there was a trade war launched by Trump in like 2017,
2018.
And it really started to have a strong effect on the Chinese, um, between that and the domestic
issues here.
Uh, it may not have been, um, it may not have been random that the, the COVID virus escaped
the laboratory or escaped the fishmongers or whatever you want to believe, right?
Uh, certainly the Chinese, right?
People with the Chinese government made public statements that they quote, won the biological
war at the end of COVID.
Now, what that means, we can all filter that through our individual ideology, but there were
definitely Chinese public officials who at the end of the acute phase of COVID were making
public statements about having won a biological war.
That's a fact.
Okay.
So, uh, during that period of time, right?
Russia invaded the Ukraine.
And again, like, this is a weird time.
Everyone has different.
So I'm not going to make a value judgment.
I'm just gonna say Russia invaded the Ukraine.
And we know that occurred.
Um, we could look at that as a, an expansion of the same crisis when you understand it.
I mean, it's just a fact that the Russians and the Chinese are, are allied and they, they
use a scissor strategy, right?
They work together strategically around the world.
Since that time, everything that has happened from the explosions and the burn farms and all
of that may be related to the conflict.
Hey, buddy, I'll give you one second.
Cause I want to hear what you have to say, maybe related to the conflict, right?
But definitely now what's going on with Venezuela and what's going on with Cuba and what's going
on with Iran, right?
Like it's containment against the Chinese, but they're also traditional Russian allies.
So you can't see it is isolated from the, the larger conflict or you can, but if you're
doing that, you're, you're being naive.
So if I were to say like, could we interpret this, the Saturn Neptune conjunction as Russia
bringing down global industrial civilization?
Yes, we could say that.
But does that mean that like, is that, is that saying like they have a plan and they know
that's, it's possible, but it's not a value judgment against them, but they themselves through
this interpretation would be related to this crisis.
And I think that's evident that that's happening, regardless of what you, of where your sympathies
lie.
It's evident that, right.
They're connected to this, this situation in, in, in many ways.
Go ahead, buddy.
I'm sorry for, for rambling on when you wanted to talk.
No, not at all.
I, um, really respect you.
And, um, you know, there's different modalities for predictions and, you know, divining different
information, past, present, future.
And I think they're all super valid.
Um, I haven't explored astrology as much as I should, but I share so many of your sentiments
from the different, um, divination methods I utilize.
And, you know, I certainly see like, uh, the Russia, China, uh, you know, the access versus
allies thing going on.
And I certainly see the hybrid warfare that's happening behind the scenes and that we're
going to see more stuff, you know, against our infrastructure, um, in a variety of different
ways and it'll get, you know, worse as time progresses.
I see things like, you know, of course the big stock crash that's going to happen next
week on the heels of this week.
And we're speaking about this stock crash, you know, six months ago, but you can look at
the metrics and a lot of different things and kind of intuit some of this stuff.
Um, but also I've had a longstanding, um, series of different modalities I've utilized
to really, excuse me, I throw it short, hone in on the Chinese aspect of it.
I think there has been a longstanding plan, um, for my divination methods and, uh, also instincts
that, uh, they want to be, and China wants to have a first emperor of the globe.
And that's something I, uh, believe has been a plan and actions have been put in place and,
uh, a whole methodology and infrastructure in place to kind of, uh, go towards that.
And it's so sad on one level, you know, I know as an intuitive yourself and the other intuitives
in this room and empathetic people that we know that the elite, uh, use war and power
to try to garner dirt and dust is what it ends up being, you know, land and other things.
When the most valuable thing we have is each other, our creativity, our ability to do things,
to innovate, and it's, it's heart wrenching.
And we're amidst a real kind of a crescendo in so much of this stuff at a time when our technology
is so dangerous.
And, um, I think, you know, with the global, uh, kind of money burn, that's going to get
worse in my, uh, projections over the next few months.
Definitely the people are going to suffer the most, the prices for foods and, you know,
basic commercial, uh, products and stuff are going to go up and those who can invest in,
you know, you know, BlackRock and the big stables, you know, uh, investments and companies that
are less service oriented, less entertainment oriented, um, uh, you know, they are going to
do well in the entertainment and, you know, a lot of the services and, you know, uh, stuff
like that are going to suffer and the people are going to suffer.
And when people do astrology, like you're doing JT and informing people what's going on, what's
coming, it allows people who are, um, the most subject to a lot of the extremes, the citizens
to prepare a little bit and to make the difficulties, um, less difficult.
And that's what, you know, shaman, witch doctors, intuitives, sages have done for a long time.
So I really appreciate you having this space and bringing information.
That's not always, you know, happy and peppy, but it's the real information as far as you
garner it.
And that's, and that's important.
You know, a real friend tells you when you have a blur on your nose or too much lipstick
on your teeth or too much AI between your ears.
So I love you.
Thank you, buddy.
I appreciate that.
Um, this is, this has always been the goal.
I've been working on this for three years on X now.
I, we did about 30 spaces last year.
Um, you know, people it's all right for people to, to look for entertainment.
Um, and unfortunately it's difficult to, to get around that, right.
To get around the fixation on entertainment that people have.
This is, it's all right.
If someone wants to have entertainment, like every, every app, every site, um, you know,
all their free time, like they work hard and the job sucks.
And you know, they, they, when they're not working and you know, the marriage sucks and
they just want to distract themselves.
Right.
Okay.
It's understandable.
Um, however, uh, the difficulty that we ran into, and it's not me cause it used to be
we, and it's not me, um, was that people aren't really, it's, it strikes me as strange because
this type of conversational venue reminds me of like a university or reminds me of like Athens,
right?
Like Socrates and like, that's, that's the type of venue for exchanging ideas.
But a lot of people that I've run into on X spaces are, are here for entertainment, like
the Jerry Springer stuff.
Um, and haven't been open to this information.
So really drilled down on it.
And, uh, you know, a couple months ago, I, I kind of like a month ago, I just said, you
know, it's probably going to be the end.
Um, but for me doing spaces, but knowing that we're getting close to this sort of blast off
for the crisis, unfortunately, this is not the blast off for the crisis, but since we're
getting close to it, I said, I'm going to do some more spaces.
Cause I'm, I don't, I don't mean to humble brag.
It's not, but I do feel concerned for people, well, like in general and specifically, like
I look out and I see you guys here and guys and girls here.
Right.
And you've been there in my spaces.
And so even though I don't know you personally, like I have a concern for you when I, I don't
want you to be caught off guard by what's coming.
Go ahead, Kiki.
Yeah.
I just wanted to add that, you know, I think with, you know, what's being said that it's
important for people to study history.
And when you study history, you see that with, you know, all empires, there's a, you know,
empires rise and empires fall.
And this is, this is normal.
And so if that is what is going to occur with the U S you know, um, I, I personally, I'd
rather live in truth and kind of just prepare for whatever comes ahead and know that, you
know, in, you know, just studying the different cultures, you know, the people rise up again,
you know?
So, um, yeah.
I hear you.
Yeah.
I mean, so the, the, without being, without getting too grim, the, the problem is what
differentiates the U S from former empires, uh, is that the, we have, we have like, um,
a gentleman's agreement or a person's agreement.
We have like a social contract with each other that we don't, we don't say we're an empire,
do we expect the provinces of this empire to say that they're part of the empire?
Right.
But from world war two to the present day, you know, uh, Germany, France, England, Australia,
you know, Italy, right?
Like if they elect someone that isn't right, that person, you know, that person loses their,
their position, right?
Like I, there, the U S has militarily occupied a large percentage of the world since world
war two.
Now we're not like, we're not the same as, or, or what we don't come across as like dictatorial,
but you know, there's no such thing as having like 30,000 armed troops in someone's country
and have that country independent.
So really the empire, right.
That the U S represents is the West and our, and, you know, it's, it's, it's, it's Japan
and Australia and, and Europe and Turkey.
And, and so this crisis, you know, it may have its epicenter in the U S, but really at what,
what is going to lead to the, the collapse of industrial civilization, not the end of technology,
but the collapse of industry through oil and fossil fuels and, and stuff and target, right?
Like the stuff you buy in target like that, that's a good way of looking at like what to measure
industrial civilization, everything inside of target.
So the, the thing that might really be the linchpin in the collapse is the U S turning in on itself.
When people say like, well, globalism will end, but, and that's a positive thing.
It may be in the longterm, but in the short term, globalism ending means like a lot of hungry people, a lot of cold people, a lot of fighting people, and not just here in the U S but everywhere.
Right.
So like what's happening right now in Straits of Hormuz, in my opinion, they're attempting to contain China and to slow the progress of the world heading into a, into a larger military conflict.
But in order to do that, you know, this, this series of events, shutting off that flow of oil, um, and fertilizer, because the fertilizer is made out of the oil and medicine, because medicine is made out of the oil.
6,000 products, right.
Um, all the, the countries that manufacture those products are a lot of the countries that manufacture those products, they're running out of fuel.
And so they got to stop manufacturing those products so that we can, they can heat their, their people's homes.
Um, or cook food, like India is having a huge crisis with cooking fuel.
Um, that's where their energy has to go to look at their own people.
And so like, for instance, one of the things I talked about in the last space I run was if you, if you are on medication, you do what you have to do to get extra medication.
Cause the medication is made out of petroleum and it's made out of petroleum in India, the generic medication.
Right.
So they anticipate it's just another, it's four to five weeks until we start to have shortages of, uh, generic medication, not just, you know, here, but everywhere.
I don't know if anyone's following what's happening in Australia, but what a shit show they're running out of fuel all over the place.
It's like trucks, you know, truckers can't deliver their food because they're running out of fuel in the desert and they're just sitting there.
It takes six to 12 weeks for a global problem to really affect the U S because we are like highly resilient.
Cause we have, you know, so many resources and we have so much industry, but we're never as resilient as the people in charge would like to believe.
And the people who have sort of an ideology of American independence, because we are in a global civilization.
So right now you could spend all day on X listening to people tell you like the U S is not going to be affected.
Now this is the exact same thing that happened at the beginning of the pandemic, right?
I, I, I'm not, again, I'm a hunger.
I'm not trying to humble brag, but I knew on January 12th, what was going to happen.
I knew about what was going to happen to lockdowns, right?
Like all that stuff was drawn up after nine 11 by the Bush administration.
Like it wasn't drawn up by the Trump administration or the Obama administration.
Like this was all like old news.
And so if you knew about that, you could look at the events that were happening.
You could predict what was going to happen.
But no one would believe it.
No one would believe that we were going to end up in this long-term global lockdown situation.
Um, or at least no one that I knew, or I spoke to, and I couldn't get on X and talk to anyone
because I'd been into a major accident and I was like, my life was touch and go at that
point time.
I had five close calls with death in that period.
Um, so I was in a role of an observer, but I did talk to friends and family and the
people that I knew and said, look, this is what's going to happen.
And we just sort of watched and they didn't believe me until it finally sunk in.
But this is the same type of lockdowns, but probably more extreme are coming.
And the goal is clearly to try to keep them out of the U S but I think what's probably going
to happen is, um, the, this, the people who are in charge right now believe that's more
feasible than it is.
And we'll, we'll trail the rest of the world, but come summertime, I think we're going to
be in a position where reality is going to be butting up against ideology here.
And so if you want to look at like, what could possibly cause, what could be the straw that
breaks the camel's back?
I can think of a few things.
Now this is about astrology, buddy is remote viewer from what I see in a very talented remote
viewer.
Um, we have a tremendous amount of remote viewing data on this stuff.
So like what buddy was talking about with China, we intuitive underground did, uh, see,
I'm still saying we, even though we've, we've, we've had a rift, a division, but intuitive
underground, you know, worked on that.
And that's absolutely true.
It's absolutely true that, uh, China is trying to overtake the U S um, and they predicted that
these problems would occur right around the time when China started to release, uh, public
information about their technological achievements, having achieved technological parity with the
U S that's happened over the last six months where the Chinese have been releasing information
about like medical, I'm sure you've all seen, like they've been talking about like the medical
advances and they've been talking about robotics and, um, uh, harnesses like, um, uh, well,
exoskeletons that people can wear in China when they go on hikes and they released information
about having created working fusion reactors.
So that information we were expecting was going to precede the escalation of a conflict between
the U S and China.
Uh, but their goal is right.
Everyone wants to be top dog.
That's what it comes down to.
And their goal is not to be our equals.
Their goal is to, um, you know, to, uh, take our place without getting into like the ideology
surrounding, um, like without getting into like talking points or whatever and being political.
I'm just saying that's, that's what it was.
That's what it is.
Um, we have astro RV data.
Um, the original thing that, um, Morgan and I worked on was the fusion of astrology and remote
viewing.
And the reason that you would do that is, um, remote viewers have a difficulty and I could,
I've done spaces on this.
Um, this is, it's too much of a digression, but there are reasons why remote viewers have
difficulty seeing beyond 18 months in the future reliably.
They can see six to 18 months in the future, very reliably beyond that.
There are actual reasons why it's difficult and utilizing, uh, astrological transits, right?
As a, um, a coordinate system, the same way you would use geographic coordinates to look at
a physical location on the planet, uh, we believe, uh, would circumvent those limitations and
allow remote viewers to, uh, reliably and accurately remote view at any point in the future.
Um, and I believe that that's what, um, like sages in the past were doing.
Like, I believe that's what old Testament prophets were doing.
I think that's what John the revelator did.
I think that's what Nostradamus did.
Like, I think this was, this isn't a new technology.
Um, it may be more formalized, but it's an old idea of using the astrological transits as, as coordinates in time.
Well, um, someone else did, uh, an astral RV session around the Saturn-Neptune conjunction.
They did it without knowing.
Uh, and it's kind of, again, it's too much of a digression to explain why they didn't know,
but they wound up on this target.
They were looking at a specific day, but the guy who wrote the, the targeting statement effed up.
And instead of looking at that day, he said, and anything that like, that, that happened, that happens as a result of the events on this day or something,
I would have to, I would have to like, um, look it up again to get the exact wording.
But anyhow, the remote viewer, um, Josh Maitland, who's, who's new, he's, he's, he's been in five years.
But, you know, he's, he has, he has skill.
Um, he's, he has accuracy.
Uh, he wound up seeing the events related to this entire transit and they involve, and I think he was on target.
Um, they involved UFO sightings and there are UFO sightings up the wazoo right now.
Um, they involved, uh, the, the, the, the war in Iran.
Um, he did this a year ago.
Uh, yeah.
So the spring of 2025, uh, the war with Iran and, um, political events in the United States,
revolutions springing up around the world and, uh, the economic issues.
Um, and, um, and then how it, how it, how it all wraps up, um, which we've done other spaces on.
We don't need to do it in this space.
Um, but there's other remote viewers who have seen the same thing, which is, this is all heading towards sort of a, a culmination with this war.
Um, so we have all that, uh, supporting data around this, uh, this astrology.
And so I try to parse it when people ask me astrological questions at this point, it's difficult for me not to add remote viewing data, right?
Because I've, I'm so, I've been, I've been sort of steeped in this for a couple of years now, but he is, is exactly on point, um, with what he is, uh, he's seen or what he's seen is, is, is, is the same thing that other viewers see pretty reliably.
Um, so yeah, certainly all the way back when you say like, you know, is there an indication that you're going to have, uh, um, a notable month next month?
Yeah, I think everyone is.
So what we're concerned about primarily, or I guess me at this point, what I'm concerned about primarily is, uh, and has been in April, uh, WMD related terrorist attacks.
I hate to even say that, right?
I'm not the only person saying it.
Um, I think everyone's on everyone's mind and I'm not saying like, this is a hundred percent what's going to happen.
I'm not saying that I'm saying like, that's what I'm concerned about.
That's what I'm afraid of based on the information that I've seen and, uh, blackouts, um, a notable, this is the, the future forecasting group, right?
They're, they're work, they're notable.
They're not the best in some ways, but, um, I think they were on target in this one.
And I think this is also what the astrology would support when Mars crosses the, um, zero degrees Aries, when it activates the Saturn-Neptune conjunction, right?
You're going to see a, uh, sudden limitation related to, um, this, this situation in the Gulf of the fossil fuels, right?
And all the damage that's being done to these refineries.
Uh, it can be a sudden limitation of the flow of oil.
So something could happen that would even like set back the flow of oils more, like significantly more than it is now.
There are limitations because of the flow of fossil fuels and the conflict around them.
And one of those potential limitations would be someone finding a way to weaponize blackouts.
It's something that we have been doing, right?
Cuba.
It's something that happened in Iraq recently.
It's something that we threatened to do in Iran.
If you recall, if you recollect, the president said, uh, like a week ago, we said, you know, 48 hours, and then we're going to take out all the electric substations and take out the grid in Iran.
And when he said that, at least made me very nervous because I'd spent so much time talking to people saying, I hope we don't have, you know, watch out for and prepare for a potential blackout in April.
And by blackout, I'm talking like more than 24 hours.
It could be three days.
It could be a week.
It could be who knows what period of time.
Possibly related to a cyber attack.
Now, like, there's no way for someone like us or me in a space on X to put an idea in the mind of someone related to Iran or some fifth column group, right?
But it almost feels guilty.
It almost feels like even just talking about it is, is, is something that is uncomfortable, right?
Um, cause you don't want to will it into existence, but it is definitely, there is, um, April 4th is, uh, well, April 1st is, is Passover, which is important in light of the religious context of the war.
So if you were going to look at a date that you would be concerned about, you would immediately look at April fool's day, which is you talking about, right?
You were talking about the, um, the full moon.
And I was going to amend that and say, it's not the full moon that I'm concerned about.
It's the fact it's Passover.
Um, then April 4th, uh, there is a sun grazing comet and sun grazing comets, um, often trigger, um, sunspots, coronal mass ejections.
And at that time, it's possible that that sun grazing comet would kick up, uh, a sunspot or a coronal mass ejection, which would weaken the grid.
If there were intelligent people, you know, working for the enemy, they might know that.
And they might know that's a time when they could, um, more easily affect some sort of villainous design.
Um, so yeah, I'm, I'm very concerned about it.
And there's actually, when Uranus goes into Gemini, right on the 24th.
So that period, the 20th to the 24th, there's another sun grazing comet on the 20th and Uranus, of course, as we all know, like,
is, is, is a, well, I guess we don't know.
So Uranus is related to crises.
Okay.
And they call it the great awakener, but they're, they're crises that we sleepwalk through life.
And that's a metaphor, but it's also real.
And what the crises, the transits of Uranus do to our, to us, when they occur to our natal chart into the world, when they occur on a mundane level, uh, Uranus transits awaken us to the fact that we have been in a, in a post-hypnotic state.
And, um, we've been sleepwalking.
It's a moment.
It's a sudden crisis that brings you to full or close to full awareness.
It usually doesn't last very long, but that's why the Uranus is both a planet of explosive crises and the great awakener.
It's the two are together the same.
Gemini is, of course, well, not of course, uh, Gemini is related to, uh, short distance travel and, um, communication.
And, uh, in some people's, some people look at Gemini as ruling electricity.
Some people look at Aquarius as ruling electricity, but it's certainly a large number of people look at Gemini as ruling electricity.
So when, um, Uranus enters Gemini, um, that is another window during April when there's a possibility of a large scale blackout, right?
That's, uh, a reasonable, go ahead, buddy.
I love, uh, your frankness and there's a lot of evidence to support this stuff.
And I have a personal, uh, curious, curiosity about your, um, viewings and your data for, uh, five years and 10 years from now and where we're going to be.
I, you know, of course, you know, personally, I see adversity kind of building, you know, job loss, global money burns, um, you know, AI's, uh, impact on jobs.
And, um, a lot of adversity in the future, um, you know, building in many ways, we're at the peak of society now, I think in many ways, um, but you know, this kind of intuitive data, and I loved what you had to say about incorporating astrology into it, because I practice a variety of modalities.
And I find that different modalities are better for different types of, um, you know, targets, essentially, um, you know, physical objects or, you know, future dates.
So I love, love, love.
And I think it's a better practice to incorporate, um, astrology and, you know, it's more senses coming together.
And, um, you know, there are the full remote viewing protocol CRV has a function in it where you can do timelines and you can do, um, dates and origins in the future, but very, very few utilize it.
Um, and, uh, you know, I'm just personally very curious about your, you know, data and intuition on, you know, where we are in five years and 10 years.
Thank you, Brad.
Okay.
Yeah, absolutely.
Um, I got to think about that for a minute.
Um, if you don't mind that, uh, I'm going to just, I don't want to lose.
I have three strands right now in my mind.
Um, so, uh, Kiki, Shane, and then buddy.
Um, although I'm not prioritizing based on who I like.
It just, that's what popped into my mind.
So, uh, Kiki, you have, I think you said Mars at five degrees areas.
I think that's what you said.
Okay.
So, um, the grand lesser trine, the, the, um, geometric relationship right now, uh, over like, well, it's, it's about a three year process, but this year specifically affects you, um, between Uranus, Neptune, and Pluto.
The next exact, um, the next exact, uh, trine, then it's actually more than that because Jupiter will be involved.
And it's a, it's a famous astrological transit.
People have been predicting since the eighties called Barbolt's basket, because Barbolt was the astrologer who first talked about it.
That occurs, uh, that occurs, uh, in August and, uh, that is going to directly, uh, trigger your natal Mars.
So, uh, over the next, like, 12 months, 12, maybe 18, again, I would have to, like, sit with it.
Um, I don't want to give you false information, but right now, uh, if you're at five degrees, Pluto is probably affecting, um, Pluto is probably in close to an exactly in a sextile.
With your natal Mars, uh, a sextile is like an opportunity.
So it's, some people swear that you absolutely are going to have a, an impact in your life.
Um, you may not be experiencing that right now.
Uh, Pluto and Mars and a sextile is, um, I don't know how I would characterize that.
I would have to think about it, um, to be honest with you.
I can say that Neptune and Mars, which is going to be exact for you next year, it's going to be activated in, um, because we don't have your houses, right?
It's going to be activated in, in August, but it's going to be exact for you in next year.
Uh, that, that is a, so I'm not saying, okay, I'm not telling you this is going to happen to you.
I'm saying like one extreme manifestation of that is like homelessness, forms of, of, of homelessness.
So we would look at your, we would look at your chart, find the house and look at that type of, um, that type of change.
So maybe not physical homelessness, but in a metaphorical sense, wherever that is, um, and Uranus sextile Mars is going to be like an awakening.
That's going to happen for you this year, August.
Um, that's going to be like, uh, a minor awakening crisis.
These are all going to flow together though.
So that's going to affect what you want to do is you want to find out like what house, uh, is Pluto in your chart right now?
What house is, is, um, is your natal Mars in what house is Uranus in?
Right.
And because those are the, the, the areas where you're going to have events, they all affect that natal Mars.
And then you want to find the houses that Mars is on the cusp of, right.
Or sorry, you want to find the houses that, um, Aries and Scorpio are on the cusp of, because those are the, the places where you're going to have like a tangible.
Result in your life.
And this is going to be big.
Like this is going to be like, this is what you're looking for.
Right.
If you, if you're feeling like something big is happening, it's because Pluto is most likely Pluto is sextile your natal Mars.
That's most likely why you're having that feeling.
And it's absolutely going to happen over the next 12 months.
And it's absolutely going to be one of the strongest astrological influences of your life.
But I can't say more than that without seeing the chart and seeing the houses, right.
How it's going to play out would vary from individual to individual.
There are thousands of possible combinations there.
Um, but you definitely want to look into that because that's, that's particularly this summer and, um, and next year.
Now that gets into Shane's question, right.
Which is, uh, when you have these, uh, uh, events, this was, I think is original question.
I mean, when you have these outer planet transits to signs, these historical periods of time.
So, like I was saying, take one example, Uranus transiting Taurus is related to right-wing populism, right.
It's complicated to understand how that actually works.
So you can say, well, when Uranus is in Taurus, we're going to see a reinsurgence of right-wing populism.
But Uranus isn't causing that.
Uranus is the awakener.
It's awakening you to it.
So the best possible example I can give you all is, regardless of your political feelings,
if you go back seven years ago, eight years ago, the majority of us were not aware that right-wing populism,
both negative and positive aspects of it, were as large in our society as we are now aware.
So one of the things that happened during the pandemic, right, the, without digressing too much,
the, the masking and the social distancing, uh, it triggered the behavioral immune system of people.
And what that does is that causes a heightened expression of behaviors to avoid people who are different than yourself.
So whenever you trigger a population's behavioral immune system, there is a spike in xenophobia and there is a spike in antisemitism.
Now, regardless of how you feel about that, like personally, that relationship is there.
It's predictable.
So, we were able to make predictions around the spike of those feelings.
Um, where am I going with this?
Holy shit.
Uh, but Uranus is not causing it.
Uranus is the experience of the crisis of awakening to it.
So Uranus is the, holy shit, there are a lot of Nazis on X.
Where did they all come from?
That doesn't mean everyone who's a right-wing populist is a Nazi.
Far from it, far from it.
But that's one of the things that would be connected to that, right?
When, when that event occurred, when everyone sort of woke up and said, wow, I didn't know there were so many people who had like overt Nazi sympathies.
Okay, now again, that doesn't reflect on everyone else's right-wing populist, but there is a connection, it's a correlation.
Um, that is what it means when Uranus goes to a sign.
So, when Uranus goes into Gemini, it's the moment where we're all like, wow, we are two different nations living in one country.
And wow, we are two different worlds living in the same world, right?
We are, we are complete, there's a complete bifurcation.
It didn't happen because of Uranus, we awaken to it because of Uranus, okay?
So, if you have a Uranus transit to one of your natal planets,
it's very likely that the experience will be related to what's happening socially regarding that transit through the sign.
But, a sign, and Uranus itself, right, can have a number of different meanings and manifestations.
So, you may not recognize it.
Uranus can be a crisis, it can be an awakening, right?
So, there's two different ways it can play out.
Taurus could be precious metals.
It can be farms, right?
Trad wife, we were talking about.
It can be right-wing populism.
So, if Taurus was your second house, right?
Then, and you had a transit to that, it could relate to the price of gold affecting you.
It could relate to you going on vacation and spending time on a farm, wanting to buy a farm, buying a farm.
It could relate to you developing an aversion to or sympathy with right-wing populism, right?
And how that would affect, so, that's the beginning.
That could be the event.
And then, you take the event and you apply it to the planet involved, right?
So, if it was your son, your son is the arrogance of the ruler.
That's where you find your son in your chart is where, it's not like you're trying to make yourself the center of attention.
You just naturally are the center of attention in a way that some people might find off-putting, to be honest.
That's the environment where you are naturally sort of take on the arrogance of the ruler, right?
So, Shane has gold bars in his closet.
Uranus is going through Taurus.
The price of gold spikes up by like 300%, which it did, right?
All of a sudden, Shane is sitting on a lot of money he didn't have before.
Yeah, that's his possessions, right?
All of a sudden, he's sitting on, and so, then we look at, we take the sun, and we look at what house the sun is at the cusp at the beginning of.
And so, it could be the seventh house.
The spike in the price of gold is related to Uranus going through Taurus.
That affects, that affects you, your sort of, your sort of, your sort of, a natural arrogance about possessions.
And the outcome of that relates to your relationship.
So, perhaps you are feeling yourself because you now have all this gold money, and so you go out and you ask the person that you've always wanted to be with, that you didn't feel confident that you could be with that person, and they're excited about the fact that you have all this gold money.
And next thing you know, you're married.
I'm just trying to piece something together, right?
Because I'm creating a hypothetical scenario.
But that would be how it would work together.
I'll give you a practical example.
I've never me-tooed anyone in my life.
One of the things that happens when you work in, like, when you do this type of work, and right now, as I've told everyone, I was in an accident.
I'm generally disabled.
But, you know, even before then, when you do this type of work, everyone has a side hustle.
Almost no one can pay their bills doing this type of work.
But no one wants to represent it that way, because then other people point the finger at you and say, oh, you know, they've got a side hustle, you've got a side hustle, but this makes you vulnerable to them using hostile marketing against you.
But we all do, all right?
So, I was at my other job, and during that period, I've never me-tooed anyone.
So, I got, like, I had Pluto conjunct my natal son.
It's in Capricorn.
So, that's business.
And it's in the 12th house, which is Hidden Enemies.
So, I was bopping along one day, and I had a young female co-worker.
We had, like, a random exchange, and she felt slighted by what I said.
And it turns out that she had, like, this, under-the-surface, like, hatred of me.
This was, like, we never even had a personal conversation, okay?
So, this is, like, don't let my imaginations run wild, because I'm actually relating what happened.
And it ended up turning into 18 months of insanity with this person creating a lot of trouble for me, because they thought I was condescending.
Which I can be.
I can be condescending.
So, maybe I was condescending, all right?
That having been said, the, that period was a period where a lot of people who had done things that they shouldn't have done were being accused of stuff.
But because of the sensitization, human resources in companies around America were taking any type of complaint very seriously.
So, for the first time in my life, I was going through this immense struggle at work.
And the accusation, the only accusation, was that I was condescending.
You shouldn't be condescending.
So, that's not a reasonable, rational thing where you would wind up in this, like, 18-month fucking ordeal, right?
And that, I did.
So, that's Pluto conjunct my son.
Like, that's textbook.
For some people, when Pluto conjuncts their son, they, like, they think they're being stalked online.
Like, it's a insidious, sinister, sort of crazy series of events.
And everyone, most of us, most of you won't live long if you haven't.
But if you've ever had Pluto conjunct his son, like, you had, like, a series of, like, sort of insidious, crazy event.
And that was mine.
And you could tell how it would work out because of, you know, Pluto was going through.
So, the insidious, crazy events were going through the workplace.
And also, people don't talk about this, but, you know, Capricorn is a female sign.
I'm not criticizing anyone.
I'm not saying there wasn't, you know, I'm just saying this is, like, related to it.
And so, whenever Pluto goes through Capricorn, historically, are periods of, like, the negative aspect of interactions with women in the workplace, historically.
So, and it goes back to, like, the people from England here know about Bodasia, right?
I might be scrambling that, but she was a leader in England.
And her, she ended up being killed, unfortunately, where she led a rebellion against the Romans.
And that happened at the beginning of a Pluto transit through Capricorn.
So, that's a famous example that people use to say what will happen.
So, like, rebellions led by women in society, in the workplace.
Again, I'm not making any judgments, but if you look at, like, what happened,
between 2008 and 2024, like, that was a, it was a strong theme.
So, I'm just trying to explain, like, how that particularly affected me.
And it was fucking ridiculous, because, again, it involved condescending.
If it was anything serious, I wouldn't, I wouldn't tell the story, right?
Not that I've ever had that.
But that gives you an idea.
Does that, does that answer your question, like, how the larger can connect with the smaller?
Like, how the, the big transit can inform the personal experience?
Or did I digress too far for it to be intelligible?
I believe so.
Okay.
I didn't want to, I didn't want to, I didn't want to cut in and steal your thunder, though.
No, you can always cut in.
Could I ram?
Yeah.
No, I didn't, no, I don't.
It's your show, and I didn't want to interrupt.
I find your, I don't know if I would say tangent, but I find it interesting and entertaining.
Oh, Buddy had a dip.
I'm sorry, go ahead, go ahead.
Oh, go ahead.
No, I just, I just remarked to myself that Buddy did before I answered his question.
But that's all right.
But, but no, yeah, that was, I mean, essentially the gist.
I was, I was wondering, you know, if you were looking at someone's chart, and you, let's
say you were looking at a series of charts, would you see, would you see a general theme?
Yeah.
That would indicate, oh, I think something big is going to happen.
And I'm, I'm assuming now listening to you, that's basically what did happen in the past
and what kind of led you down this road.
Yeah.
And it's, it's definitely the case.
Like these, the, the way it affects us personally depends, varies by the house that that's involved.
But it's the same, like these, these social trends, right?
We call them trends.
These social trends governed by the transits of the outer planets through the signs shape
our lives.
Pluto is a good example.
I was born with Pluto in, in, uh, Libra.
Uh, Libra represents not always, but it often represents marriage.
Right.
And, um, when I was younger, the insidious force that was threatening society was the breakdown
of marriages.
That was the first divorce epidemic.
And then this is the, okay.
This is touchy, but, uh, next, right.
Pluto goes through Scorpio and amongst other things, Scorpio rules taboo sexuality and the
AIDS virus emerged relatively, um, relatively quickly after, uh, Pluto entered Scorpio.
Um, and so the insidious force that was threatening society was the AIDS virus, HIV.
Now that would have had, right.
When it was in Libra, uh, people would be experiencing, um, sort of insidious, crazy events related to
their parents' marriage or their own marriage.
When it was in Scorpio, even if you never had anything personally, like if you never had any personal close
calls with the HIV virus, like everyone, it was, it's hard to, it's for some, if you, if you weren't
there, it's hard to, to explain like how the level of hysteria, not that it wasn't serious.
It was, but it became this Pluto stuff always becomes a hysteria, right?
Um, Oh yeah, it was, it was, it was absolutely blown out of proportion back then.
Oh yeah.
I mean, I remember, I believe I was in third or fourth grade and when HIV hit and, uh, yeah.
And I just remember, uh, I mean, people pulling kids out of school and having large meetings about it and just, uh, so much fear.
And it builds up when, when you get a transit, right, it builds up as it goes through the sign.
So at the very end, right.
Uh, or a couple of years before the very end, I was, I was a senior in high school and they told us, uh, you will
know 1 billion people are going to die of AIDS.
You're going to know family members and friends.
You're going to like, this is what they were teaching us in school.
Like this wasn't like a matter of, um, opinion for them.
They were teaching us in school.
This was, this was our life going forward.
This is what was going to happen.
A billion people are going to die of AIDS.
We're all going to know someone who's going to die of AIDS.
Right.
And then as soon as Pluto moves into Sagittarius that disappears.
And, uh, now it's, uh, people, uh, it's religious people in foreign lands.
Right.
And so we were the religious fanatics in foreign lands for the Iraq or for the Middle Easterners
and the Middle Easterners and the Muslims were the religious fanatics in foreign lands for us.
And that was the insidious force working itself threatening society that led to, uh, for us,
right, 9/11 and other terrorist attacks.
And for them, you know, an invasion of, of, uh, a foreign army from overseas that, that created,
uh, uh, terror for them.
And then, uh, Pluto moves into, uh, Capricorn.
Right.
And, uh, first thing that happens is the financial crash.
And the second thing that happens is the, um,
the social restructuring, um, related to unaddressed past grievances.
I mean, I think is the best way to put it.
Right.
Um, and then as soon as Pluto moved into, uh, Aquarius, that was October 7th.
Well, right around the time it was October 7th.
And, um, you know, like I said, Pluto and Aquarius is, is religious, uh, crusades.
Right.
So immediately, um, everyone sort of started to get this thing in the Middle East, galvanized,
sort of, um, began to divide the world, um, along those lines.
And we've been in this Middle Eastern crusade since, um, which is only going to continue to get bigger.
Uh, so yeah.
And that would have effects.
Like, so if you had a Pluto transit right now, it would probably be related to
the events in the Middle East, or it would be related to like the blackout,
because that's another, um, potential with, uh, or AI, uh, you know, um, UFOX, right?
How many people in UFOX have, uh, the new aids, right?
Artificial intelligence induced, um, delusions.
That is also, uh, Pluto and Aquarius.
So if we took someone like say God sauce, I think everyone here knows God sauce.
I'm not criticizing the person.
I'm saying that he's, you know, he has some pretty heavy stuff going on with AI.
And if you look at his, uh, chart, it's quite possible, quite likely that he would be experiencing
one or more, uh, transits from Pluto to natal planets or, or points on his chart at this point
in time.
And probably most people who have like heavy AI involvement are.
So that's be how it works, right?
Like, so the scourges, uh, the scourges, uh, loss of power, uh, religious crusades and artificial
intelligence right now.
Um, would be where we look for the insanity.
In the, uh, in the astrological charts is the rise of AI, um, could be speculative in there.
Could, could you maybe have seen it coming?
Sure.
Yeah.
A lot of people do.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well, cause, uh, technology is generally, um, technology is generally connected to Aquarius
because Aquarius, one of the archetypes of Aquarius is the inventor.
So, um, guys like, um, and I don't think Elon has, I haven't, I forget his chart.
I've seen it, but I, I can't tell you anything about it.
Right.
Like he's very Aquarian.
Um, but like, uh, the idea of, um, Nikola Tesla, people, Nikola Tesla, like people like
that without looking at their charts, but they, they have sort of the Aquarian archetype.
Um, and so because of that technology and electricity are often seen, some people see electricity
as part of Gemini anyhow.
Um, but any of that stuff like computers is, is considered to be Aquarian because of the
connection to inventors, even though it would usually be connected to Gemini, um, because
of the connection between Gemini and communication and, um, yeah.
So yes, uh, people were writing for years that, uh, we would see the dark side of AI, uh, as
soon as, um, Pluto moved into Aquarius.
And we did, uh, what I have argued for years is that, um, uh, Pluto's presence in Aquarius
isn't just, uh, danger from, right?
Cause Pluto is never just, uh, an insidious force in one direction.
It works in both directions.
So it's danger from and danger to, right?
So at the same time that technology becomes a danger, um, or a form of like madness in society
or a form of, um, um, of, uh, intimidation, like a sort of a sinister aspect of society.
At that same time, um, there's, uh, a sinister threat to technology.
So the best way to, um, possibly, uh, articulate that is to say, like, look at the data centers,
right?
Like, uh, last year and into this year, the big problem was we've got all these data centers
that are popping up all over the place.
They're sucking up all the natural gas.
And instead of paying for their own natural gas, which is the craziest thing, I think,
in the last 12 months, like even crazier than the war, right?
Is, uh, the, um, the fact that these data centers were sucking up the natural gas and then
the rates for the natural gas was going up instead of them paying for it.
All the customers in the area were suddenly getting charged like $6,000 for their electric bill,
which is generated from natural gases in these areas, right?
Just batshit crazy stuff.
That's, that's, that's Pluto, uh, that type of batshit crazy, um, experience.
Now, all of a sudden we've got this, uh, straight up homoose crisis and they're saying,
shit, all these data centers could be completely screwed.
And in, in less than a year, we've gone from like data centers being a threat to the people,
which is also Aquarius.
Aquarius represents communities of people, um, unions, mobs, uh, fraternal organizations.
So, um, the data centers have gone from being threatened, uh, or threat to people to being
threatened by the, the lack of electricity potentially, right?
That's, that's all in the same, that's all derived from one interpretation of one outer plan of transit.
And I'm sorry if I put everyone off by saying that I, I had a minor me too, because it wasn't a me too
experience experience, but it was at that same time.
And so I liken it to, I noticed a couple of people dropped off and ah, fuck it, whatever.
Um, but it's true.
It's like, it's, I know those of us who like live in areas like Massachusetts, it's still sort of
uncomfortable to talk about.
If you live in an area like Texas, you know, they'll, they'll laugh and joke about it.
Um, but there was a lot of collateral damage and there always is with Pluto transits collateral
damage is really what you're looking for, right?
So as the transit of Pluto goes on in Aquarius, cause that, that disappeared, right?
Like the, all of that collateral damage related to those social movements disappeared relatively
quickly.
It always does what you have to worry about now collateral damage wise, right?
So it's like the power going out, that's, that's, um, your power bill going up because
the data center is like, that's the type of collateral damage you have to look at.
As time goes on, um, Pluto and Aquarius is, is, is bad.
Like it's a, it's a, it's a bad time.
Like we idolize the last period in time where Pluto went through Aquarius because that was
the revolution, right?
But it was also the French revolution.
And even with the American revolution, like we've really sanitized it and cleaned it up.
It was a lot worse.
And then, then most people realize like people had a, had a pretty tough time in this country.
Um, including periods where they were like cut off from, uh, power and resources.
So, uh, Boston, Boston was, uh, under siege for a year or close to a year.
Uh, there was no food coming and going.
There was, uh, no oil getting in.
They couldn't heat their homes.
They didn't have any firewood.
So like the stuff that we're afraid of happening now because of the Straits of Hormuz, that stuff
happened to colonial cities, including the one, right?
I live in, in, in the outskirts of greater Boston.
Like that happened during the revolution during this last, um, period of Pluto and Aquarius.
Uh, so that's like something.
And then danger from mobs.
It may not be the case where you live.
Um, but some of us are going to live in cities or urban areas where there's a danger from,
from mobs and, um, something I've long predicted.
I don't think anyone else has, uh, when you look at, um, periods where a planet goes through a sign,
it doesn't just affect, uh, that sign.
It affects the signs are at right angles to it or, uh, 180 degrees, 90 degrees.
That's the geometry of conflict in astrology.
So, um, 180 degrees from, uh, Aquarius is Leo.
And that's why when Pluto goes through Aquarius, like the French revolution and the period of
the French revolution and the period of the American revolution, um, that's why they throw
off monarchs and aristocracy.
So in the U S we, we kicked everyone out who supported the King.
We drove them into Canada, fought a war, uh, made it illegal for anyone to have a, a title.
Um, it couldn't be a Earl or a Duke or a Baron or anything and live in the United States and be
a citizen.
And we, um, we severed with the King in France.
They rounded up anyone who was an aristocrat or related to them and put them to death, right?
Uh, France is a,
is a country that's, uh, ruled by Leo.
And so, uh, events in that, or so is Iran.
Iran is a country that's, it's a, a Leonine country.
So if you look at what's happening in Iran, um, as opposed to everywhere else,
that's most likely because Iran is, uh, a Leonine country, uh, during a Pluto transit through Aquarius.
Influencers, right?
Like people who have a hundred thousand, um,
a hundred thousand followers, subs, a million followers and stuff.
Not, not people have like 3000 or 5000, but they are the petty aristocrats of our time.
And, um, um, I believe that as time goes on, as we see the inflation and the depression,
uh, financial depression and the warfare and the food shortages, the images of people in
exotic places, doing exotic things aren't going to age very well.
This is, this is what I've been saying this for years.
Um, and resentment is going to build up.
I, America is pretty permissive, so I don't think it will be, I, I, it's not going to be the same
here that it will be in, in other areas of the world, just based on our last experience.
And I can't say that for certain.
I hope that it will still be rather moderate here.
Um, I don't think that people who are influencers are going to be rounded up in the U S they might
at some point, but I do think there are other areas in the world where they will be.
Another aspect that I don't mean to offend anyone.
Okay.
Like I always have to say this because I do offend people.
Anyhow, just by being frank, um, only fans, that's not going to age well.
And again, it will be different in the U S from other areas.
And hopefully in the U S, uh, it will continue to be more moderate than it has been in other
areas, but there will certainly be areas of the world where, um, people who presently or formerly
were influencers presently or formerly were involved in only fans and stuff like that will
face tangible consequences in their life for that.
And I've, I've been saying this from the very beginning.
Like I said, don't, you know, I used to tell people they won't listen to me.
And I tell these kids that don't get involved in that shit because believe me,
when you're older, um, you're going to have real consequences.
Not just like when people talk to you about it and say, oh, you'll get this when you're older.
Like, no, like we're going to go through a period of time where there'll be tangible resentment,
um, towards people who are involved in that stuff.
Uh, so I, I would count on that French revolution type stuff in Europe and other, you know, Iran
is another one, right.
Is a leaning country like areas, specific areas.
Um,
there will be French revolution type behavior towards influencers over the next 20 years,
like throughout the entire period of 20 years, but it could happen next year.
I mean, if, if the situation is, is bad enough.
So that's like, that's how these events interact.
So without a planet chain, uh, Pluto is, um, it's evil and monitors aren't supposed to say that,
but it's true.
It's an evil force.
It represents insidious adversarial, uh, danger.
So, um, things that are small or things that seem small.
Uh, so Pluto represents like the COVID pandemic.
Like that's why the connection between Pluto and pandemics, especially when it conjuncts Saturn,
because it represents like tiny dangerous things you can't see.
Uh, it also represents aliens.
Uh, some people say it's Uranus, but it's, it's Pluto.
It represents like the, the danger at a distance.
So like, we wouldn't say aliens are tiny, but they're, they're small to us because they're
in at a distance, right?
Like far away is a, is a similar to being small.
Uh, it's like an alien danger, um, danger from microbes, um, danger from political ideologies,
things like that.
We can assign that to, uh, Pluto, like kind of crazy types of danger.
Uh, Neptune is illusion.
So, so basically, I'm sorry.
So basically, uh, like a fear of the unknown.
No, it's, it's not the fear.
It's the, it's the danger from the unknown.
Danger from the unknown.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, Pluto is, uh, uh, Uranus connects to like explosive crises, but Pluto transits to your,
both in the worlds and to your natal chart represent long periods of like insidious tension and danger.
Like, uh, you know, my, my story is actually kind of muted.
Like I, I, the reason I'm so comfortable telling it.
And then I realized I shouldn't be right is because my Pluto conjunct my natal son.
And that experience is actually like a, a relatively normal experience.
Uh, I've run into a lot of people who, that cyber stalking where they think that like people
are sending EMF radiation through their walls and, you know, whispering crazy stuff in their minds.
Like, like that is not an uncommon experience to people who are having Pluto conjunct the natal son.
Like it's that type of insidious fear, terror, danger, tension.
And on a global level, it's, it's real danger.
It's danger to your life.
Like AIDS was a real danger.
Um, Islamic terrorism or the U S foreign intervention was a real danger.
Um, the financial danger from, uh, from the great recession, like that was a real danger to people.
Um, so anything involving Pluto is, is real crazy, real insidious, real dangerous, um, evil type stuff.
Uh, anything involving Neptune is, um, illusion, delusion, and addiction.
So, uh, you can have synchronicity and inspiration and you have these really mystical experiences,
but oftentimes it winds up being, um, delusional and, uh, or addictive.
So, uh, if you have a personal Neptune transit, it's a time when you like fall deeply in love with someone.
And then you wake up two years later and like, you never knew them at all.
Like they were just a really terrible human being and you would idolize them and thought they were wonderful.
That's like a Neptune transit.
And on a global level, um, that can be, we're talking about like, uh, crusades, right?
Where people go off to fight wars based on this, like ideology and based on like divine inspiration, but it ends up being like a war.
Right. And it ends up, you know, being horrible at the end.
Um, the problems the U S had, again, this is political, right?
I'm not political, but like there were tangible problems under the previous administration,
right? Administrations, right?
In the U S and those were all connected to, um, Neptune's transit through Pisces,
which is a period we have. Okay. Again, I don't mean to offend anyone.
I'm just going to tell you historically when Neptune transits through Pisces, you have a lot of mass migration.
And when Neptune transits through Aries, um, you have a reversal of that.
That's not new. This is, this happens historically.
Um, and then, uh, Uranus is, um, but you know, our stuff, Shane, you've seen it. So, you know, like,
you know, we, well, I say, I still say we, right. Uh, you know, I, and the, and the intuitive
underground guys, like we see the, this reality is a simulation, right? Basically reality. Okay. So, um,
the moments, uh, so Pluto would be the danger inheriting the simulation, the, the loose farming.
Um, Neptune would be the connection to the unconscious, the part of us that's sleeping,
the part of us outside of the, the simulation and Uranus are the moments where we have
complete awareness, the moments where something shocking happens and you're like,
it's shocking. And it's so shocking that everything suddenly seems unreal.
Like that can't be real. And you look around your life and you're like,
I have been sleepwalking and like everything that happened before is suddenly very unreal.
And then you have a brief period before you start to get caught up in life again.
And you, um, you sort of return to that state you had been in before from the perspective of
like the reality overlay, those moments of waking, the purpose of Uranus is to, to bring us to full
awareness of the fact that we are in an artificial, that's why it's the great awakener. It awakens us
to the fact that we're in an artificial reality. Most people aren't going to have that experience,
right? Uh, most people are going to just have like, um, I've been sleepwalking my whole life type of
experience or like sometimes Uranus will, um, will indicate a new relationship and like with someone
you would never have considered being in a relationship with. And the awakening there is like,
you've been limiting yourself or we're limited by society or whatever from having this relationship.
It's that type of thing. Um, of the three opinions differ, right? But there's a whole, um,
a whole type of astrology that's, that is based around the principle that Uranus represents God.
Um, if you look at like the work of Rudolf Steiner, um, Pluto would be Aramon, uh, Neptune would be
Lucifer and Uranus would be Christ basically. Um, and that's in Uranus is, is looked at as being the planet
that represents Jesus. So if someone is religious, um, yeah, that, so I guess that's all I have to say.
I'm just on a tangent again. That's not what I do. Um, when given the opportunity, if I don't have someone
talking to you directly, so is there anything more that I can add to that? Or have I just like really
beat it down so much that you've gotten everything from it? I, I think it's great. Um, you know,
I actually think you're incredibly intuitive. I, um, like Kiki, I had written out some questions and, um,
about an hour ago, you said a name in history. You said Joan of Arc. And actually I was,
I wrote her name down as an example in one of the questions I had. So I actually find it, um,
very interesting that you've mentioned that name just out of thin air. Um,
and the question I had related to her was if you were just to look at the, uh, astrological charts and,
you know, in general for the world, could you potentially see that an important figure like a
Joan of Arc was going to be born around this time? And, um, and cause I kind of want to parlay that into,
you know, again, if someone's religious, well, I've heard a lot that people think the Antichrist
or, uh, an Antichrist type figure might be alive on this earth now. And I was wondering if,
if you see hints of that. Okay. So that's, um,
there is astrological. I'm going to start from the end and work back. There are astrological, um,
uh, astrological images, imagery. There is astrological imagery in the book of Revelations that serves as a,
a dating, a timestamp. There is, uh, uh, what's happening in the book of Revelations, right? Is he's
looking at the sky when he's having this experience and he's seeing signs in the sky. And that's,
a lot of people don't remember that until they go back and read the book. So he takes this substance
given to him by an angel. He looks into the sky and he sees these events up in the sky,
as opposed to like looking at a crystal ball or something. And part of that, there is a,
a series of events involving, uh, Virgo, right? Um, that's imagery involving Virgo. That's,
that's there in the text as like the, um, the, um, the woman, um, who gives birth,
that the church embodied as a woman, uh, who gives birth to the son of man. When you look at that,
there's, there's actual astrological, um, alignments found in that, in that text. It's not like
hidden or whatever. And it's a once in 6,000, everything's in once in 6,000 years in astrology.
You'll hear that all the time. In my life, there's been so many once in 6,000 year, but there always
are right. Um, alignments. So that's a once in 6,000 year alignment and it occurred on September 23rd,
2017. So that's where the intersection of, uh, revelations and astrology is. Now, when I get to,
uh, can we see that in the astrology absent of the, the prophetic imagery? Yeah, absolutely.
That's what we're talking about with this, um, lesser trying right now. Uh, birth times.
There's the time someone is born and then there's the time they emerge into the world. And
with what you're talking about, there's also the potential of the
incarnation being separate from the birth. Uh, so a person can have a spirit, uh, possess them,
right? And if you were perfectly possessed, this is all hypothetical. If you were perfectly
possessed, that would be a form of incarnation. So if, uh, uh, doom or daddy were the antichrist,
I'm not saying he is, if he were, uh, he may not have been born the antichrist. He may have been
born to be the antichrist, but becomes the antichrist at some point when he's possessed by some sort of
non-human intelligence. The reason I articulate that is that yes, there are individuals, um,
who, who fit those bills alive on earth today. Uh, I would not want to talk to you
here in this space about the antichrist figures found in the book of revelations.
I, in my opinion, it's fairly obvious, but it's so loaded that it would just lead to
a lot of negative feelings. Oh, it's, it's fine. Yeah. I don't, I, you don't have to know names.
Yeah. It's actually, I want to add an addendum. Hold on. Okay. There is somebody who is not
that large in the world stage, but is on the world stage and is, is active, um, on social media,
who is most likely one of those figures that you talked about, um, found in the work of, uh,
Rudolf Steiner. So there's the biblical antichrist stuff. And then there's like predictions aside from
the Bible. And one of the most famous is a prediction by Rudolf Steiner of the incarnation of Arama.
I did, uh, two spaces on that last year, I think, um, where I detailed the events and my connection to
the events, how I had sort of a personal connection to this series of events in 1999, which is the time.
And it was the place, the American Southwest where that was predicted. And there was somebody,
again, I'm not going to name his name because if, if I, if I say who he is, I leave this on here.
It's not a matter of just like offending someone or getting someone in trouble with someone. It's like,
what if somebody who's a little unstable, here's it. Right. And I mean, even though I don't have any
influence, there's still a potential, like, you don't want to say like that person is the antichrist
or, or that person is the incarnation of Arama, even if you believe it, because you would never want
like some random person down the line, hearing that and doing something. Uh, but yes, like I,
I know someone very specifically. Um, I see them on social media. I see them, um, in visual media
and they fit every bill, um, for, for instance, that incarnation of Arama. I've looked at their
astrological chart. It's not there when they're born, but it is there, um, on August 11th, 1999,
which was the date that was predicted for the incarnation. So, uh, it's possible to see it when
they're born, but it's also possible to see like when they become that individual, hypothetically,
this could all be, and this is just thought exercise when we get into something like predicting who is a,
a non-human intelligence. I wouldn't even say antichrist right here. Like who is an,
who, who is walking around right now on earth was actually a non-human intelligence, or from our
perspective, somebody from outside the matrix, from outside the reality overlay. We definitely think
there are people, at least one in particular, um, some people believe there are 200 of them, actually.
Um, some remote viewers have, uh, have predicted that there are actually a couple hundred of them, um, on the planet.
Uh, that's interesting. I've never heard that theory before. That's really interesting.
The fallen angels, right? The 200 fallen angels. Okay. Okay. Yeah. Um, so there are, uh, viewers who have viewed
outside the reality overlay. Uh, when someone goes looking for it, you tend to discount it as opposed to
someone who doesn't expect it. Uh, so there are a lot of viewers see that type of stuff, but, um, in particular,
there, there have been at least one, if not a couple of viewers who have seen that. Um, and it's interesting.
This is another synchronicity because that was my next space on Thursday. I was planning on doing
a space called 200 griefers. Um, basically making the case of the people that we look at as fallen angels
could also be people from outside the reality overlay who are here, you know, having a virtual reality
experience. And because they're here having a virtual reality experience,
they may behave in a very griefer esque way, right? Where they're doing atrocious, horrible
crimes basically, right? Where they're committing these atrocious, horrible, horrible crimes because
for them, this is a virtual reality simulation. So they're acting like teenagers do when they play, uh,
grand theft auto. Yeah, that now see, that makes sense when, when you look, listen or hear about the,
the, uh, Epstein files, so to say everything I hear about some of the people involved in this,
it, it only makes sense to me that they're playing a game or they feel like they're playing a game
because how can you act like that? You know, that's, I know a story, probably a conversation for another
day, but it's just, um, it, it, it kind of fits into what you're saying, right? The,
It does. And it does both in, um, Oh, sorry, go ahead. Oh no, it's okay.
Okay. So it does from their behavior, but also, um, the cats are back. Uh,
I love the cats. I don't mean to sound like, um, yeah, feed me is exactly what's up. Yeah. He,
it's, uh, it's 40 minutes until it's dinner time. And, uh, they always start asking for dinner,
uh, two hours and 40 minutes before dinner time. Um, including waking me up in the morning. Uh,
that's, that's my morning every morning. Anyhow. Um, so the purpose of the reality overlay,
the purpose of the simulation, if you want to call it a simulation matrix reality overlay,
or one of the purposes is to create a, um, is to, is to, uh, the same way we,
we want AI to like develop drugs and, and create inventions. It's to create emergent solutions to
problems, but it's to create emergent solutions. The problems don't even exist yet. So basically to
comply, to compile a set of solutions to a near infinite number of problems. And if you've ever
wondered like why life is such a brutal slog and why so many outrageous things happen to a regular
person in the course of their life, or if you start from the scientific perspective, the biological
perspective of natural selection, right? Which is natural selection is, um, is basically like nature
creates as much suffering as possible. And then someone finds a solution to escape that suffering by
transferring, externalizing the suffering to someone else, right? Like if you're, if you're a bee
that suddenly can get 10% more sugar, then 10% of that sugar is gone from the other bees, right?
Like if you succeed in getting all the sugar, then other bees are starving. And we don't like to look
at that as being the reality, the world we live in, but it is. So every problem is someone else's solution
to another problem. And that's not just like on a one-to-one basis. That's like every aspect of
reality. It's trillions of data points, all of them problems that are actually solutions to other
problems. So it's like, um, an incubator for solutions dialed up to like 1 trillion.
Like as high as you can possibly imagine, like creating as many problems as possible
in order to generate as many emerging solutions as possible, even though an emerging solution is
probably one in a million. So, uh, 1 million people stub their toe so that one person can create shoes.
But look at how far this has gone, like with the level of technology we have now, right? Like,
so when people are saying, because we're at this crisis point, we're at the, we're at a crisis point
and we're at a point where like the, the metaphor I would use is the CPUs, right? They want to like,
I'm not a computer person, but like, I think everyone else understands that better than I do. Right? Like
they're going to try to re reduce the, um, the amount of energy that's being spent on this simulation.
And we're experiencing that as this global crisis, um, which will lead to like the reduction in standard
of living and unfortunately the reduction of population. Um, so this is the period where they're
trying to, or they, right? This is all rhetorical. This is all a thought exercise are trying to generate
as many solutions as possible at one time. And so when you look at the news and you see like every
day, there's a hundred new health, uh, studies are being released. And where did these studies come
from? And all these inventions, where did these inventions come from? Like I see people all the
time on X saying like, where did all this come from? And a lot of them assign it to the president,
but like before the president, everything was stagnant. And then now, you know,
the white hats have taken over and they're releasing all this backed up. Um, all these backed up inventions
and shit from our perspective, it's actually just part of the, like the last part of one phase of the
cycle, right? Of the program, the purpose for the program, the purpose for the reality of like, uh,
I don't know where I'm going with this, Shane. I think I just talked myself in the corner. Um,
that's okay. Yeah. But that's what it is. Like, that's what the purpose is.
Well, that's why there are all these problems and their behavior. Oh yeah.
No. Okay. That's why that's why they're here. They're griefing from this perspective. Again,
this is a story. It's a thought exercise, but they're also here to personally intervene,
to optimize the solutions for their problems, right? Or their potential problems. So you would look for
individuals who are very successful and very notable for solving large scale problems
who also might be on the, in the Epstein files, basically. Go ahead, man.
And, um, and that's maybe how they're right now being allowed to get away with it.
Um, but, you know, it almost seems like what you're saying is the simulation, uh, has reached its
maximum, uh, RAM capacity and, um, yeah. Yeah. And it, and, and it seems like they're running
or some of the simulations they've been running are kind of colliding together where
we have that theory of, um, um, um, like the Mandela effects.
Correct.
So, um, and they might be actually shutting down these simulations.
Yes, man. It's like, it's, it's almost like brain breaking here, but sure. And the disappearance of
the RAM, right. You're actually seeing because what, so when we talk about like, for instance,
this is a big thing with like doom, the doom room, right? The pole shift and the coronal mass ejection.
And it's a big thing in remote viewing the kill shot, which is their term for the, um,
coronal mass ejection, right. That, uh, many remote viewers have predicted will, will be sort of like the
end of this stage of history. Uh, when we had a remote viewer who looked into it off her own account,
um, she was actually looking at the hill, the whole telepathy tapes. And as an extension of looking at the
hill, the telepathy tapes, she got a session data related to the, um, the solar, uh, sorry,
the magnetic pole shift on earth related to a solar flare. So a solar flare happens as a magnetic pole
shift on earth. And the data she got showed that that magnetic pole shift was our internal experience
of them wiping the drive. So outside they're switching off the machine inside, right. The experience is
of this flash of light, this magnetic shift, and that de gauses the individuals who are alive and they
actually forget, which is something that comes up, you know, related to this event is that the people who
survive it. Um, and some people say this has happened in the past when they've had these magnetic pole
shifts, the individuals who survive it no longer remember anything, but they have amnesia. And when
this viewer looked into it, the amnesia inside the reality overlay is related to the de gaussing on the
outside or the, the wiping of the disc. And they, they see something, some sort of physical disc, some sort of
physical, yeah, it's crazy, but it's predictable. Right. Yeah. So, so we are essentially the ghost in the
machine. And when, when the simulation's over and they wipe it clean, we are alive, we are sentient.
And, uh, I guess our energy can't go anywhere or it restarts when they reset the eliminate the
simulation. And I mean, I'm just speculating. Um, but yeah, and then we do it over. It's really
interesting.
Oh, sorry. I'm talking that my microphone is off. Oh, of everything that we've talked about,
the thing that makes people most uncomfortable, right? Oh, fuck. I gotta, I gotta get this cat out of
here. Um, okay. So I know, all right. It humanizes me at least. So at, we were talking about like,
information coming up in remote viewing sessions immediately prior to changes in society that seem
to act as feedback for that information. So an example was, uh, the, the RAM. You're saying like,
the simulation is running out of RAM. And at the same time, this metaphor is occurring to people,
because we've talked about it for a little while now, but there's an actual RAM shortage on earth.
Okay. It's a, it's a, it's, it's a certain type of synchronicity in this thought exercise. Um,
last year or the year before, uh, right around that time, 2024, 2025 is when they started, uh,
at least they publicly came out and talked about creating computers using human brain cells.
And, uh, they had, um, they sell them because $35,000. They're like a little box and inside the box,
they have the, um, the brain cells and the advantage, uh, they're made in Australia actually,
which is interesting because Australia is about to turn into hell, uh, like it did in 2020 or 2019.
Um, so, uh, the advantage of that is that, um, living cells learn, uh, actively and create
actively as opposed to having to be trained. So the idea is, is that creating computers out of,
um, brain cells and supposedly they use mice cells for these computers, mice brain cells,
but who knows what is actually in there, um, creating hard drives. One, the DNA is actually
capable of storing an amazing amount of data, like more data than any physical hard drive can. And two,
the, the brains themselves working as a computer learn more effectively. So they're, they're actually,
um, a better computer for developing emerging solutions than anything technological that we
have. So they actually designed these things. They taught them to, to play pong last year. And then the
news this year, uh, last month was that they had, uh, taught them to play doom, which is extremely gothic
because doom is like, um, I guess you're in hell basically like you're in hell. It's a shooter
game in hell. Well, they taught the, the mouse brains, how to play that. So, um, going back a
couple of years, the information that, uh, we have, but that's been coming up in these RV sessions going
back years now, but it took me, I mean, I don't, again, I don't want to humble brag, but I was the one who
put the data together. And then I went to the remote viewers and said, I understand what your data says
that you're missing. Um, is, is that, that's what the machine is like the, um, we're real people, not
just ghosts in the machine because we're like, we're real, we're running on biological hardware.
Um, the, the reality overlay runs on biological hardware. So it's a machine with, yeah. So when,
when you switch it off, the hardware that we run on is still alive. Now, what the data from the IU
says is that the whole thing is, this is, I know, again, it's a thought exercise because this is going
to be out there and there's going to be like, you know, someday they're going to be asking me
questions about this and why did you say that crazy shit? So the thought exercise is that the,
the machine itself is powered by souls. That's what they see, right? They see people going to tubes
and not coming out. And the, um, the singularity is what they call it. The point of consciousness,
the point of energy that each individual has is actually being used to power the experiment.
So in that sense, like the souls are there and the biology is there. Um, it gets even crazy, Shane,
uh, some new RV data from another person who, who wasn't intending to look into this subject, but
sort of, um, went in like, um, inadvertently, uh, they even came up with that amount of time.
Like they, they, um, they believe that the, this has been going on for four years in base reality,
like human history. So, uh, one of these 200 griefers, one of these archons right there,
they can live a human life in an hour or two and then go eat lunch and then go back in.
I'm not making this stuff. I'm like, all I'm doing is reporting what other people said.
The only part of this that came from me was the recognition. And this was prior to the public,
um, release of the fact that they're now making computers with, um, with, you know,
running on brain cells years ago. I, I looked at all the session data and I said,
what you guys are missing is that this is, this is using biological hardware. And it's clear
in, cause I didn't know what they were seeing, right? So they have it, they have the data,
but they didn't know how to analyze it because they'd never imagined that scenario.
Uh, and actually I wasn't the first person to saw it. Brett Stewart, um, they're going to get angry
now that I said his name, but, uh, he, he, um, apparently recognized it as well. Some years ago,
looking at the data cause it's there. Um, yeah, but that's the part that really disturbs people.
It's not the idea. You can tell people, yeah, you're in a reality overlay,
you're in a matrix. Um, you're in a computer, you're part of a computer program and they're fine with
that. Uh, they don't, they're, they're okay. But when you say the system is running on biological
hardware, um, cell neurological material taken from political prisoners, um, that's when it gets kind
of creepy and Gothic and people get overwhelmed. That was not the subject today though. The subject
today was the astrology. And now someone's going to listen to this, um, when they see it up on X and
they're going to go, they're going to go through the whole, right. They're going to go through like
Neptune and Uranus and, and then they're going to get to the end and they're going to hear this, uh,
gothic stuff about, um, about being in a collection of brain cells in a, in a little box, you know,
it's, it's okay, man. I think it's the way, uh, the conversation went. And like I said, you,
you, um, actually glossed over the one thing I said, where I think you're highly intuitive yourself. And,
um, it was something that was definitely has been on my mind and consuming my thoughts and,
uh, I'm sure other people in the room. So you might just be picking up on it and
you're freestyling and, uh, it is what it is, but you know, those, um, doom the video game that,
they're doing in Australia. It's, it was, uh, it's actually human brain cells, um,
about 200,000. Yeah. So it's not mouse. It was actually human brain cells. And
I remember reading that they somehow figured 200,000 was about, about the limit where they were
comfortable with, uh, having to train that game and not have to question if it could become sentient,
which kind of boggled my mind. Like how, how can you put a number or a limit on that? Um,
I think if it's learning how to play games, of course, right?
Yeah. Yeah. If it's learning how to play games, right.
It's not being taught. So that's the advantage. Yeah. Is that the biological material doesn't have
to be taught. We, we generate emergency solutions without having being, without being trained to do
so just in our natural quest to escape suffering. Um, and the thing about this is, is once you recognize
this is why it's so life-changing for me to run into the IU material. And it took me two years or three years
before I could admit to myself that that part that we were just talking about, like I would feel
disquieted when I would read it. And I read it like three or four times over the years. And I didn't
know why I was sort of disturbed by it. Um, and then I realized that I, I'd been in denial about what I
was reading. Uh, and, and then I recognized why I was disturbed. Um,
yeah, that's, so that's the advantage, right? And so that's what we do. And that's what natural
selection is. That's what, that's like, once you recognize that as the master key, like everything
makes sense. A lot of people will never even use this as a thought exercise, but if you can take
this principle and apply it to pretty much any question that you have about life. And, um, it
suddenly all makes sense. Like it's like a unifying theory and I haven't found an exception to that.
Like once you recognize this, everything falls into place. So, and I, I wish, I mean, you know,
again, thought exercise, I'm not telling people what they should believe. Um, the majority of people
who remote viewers who get involved in, in these targets, uh, most of them have no idea what they're
going to see. They are not expecting what, what happens. And after they have this information, they,
they have breakdowns. Uh, most of them leave remote viewing. Um, the ones who stay will, um,
will often have a reaction where a couple of years later, they become like very vehement that
they were wrong. They were off target, that what they saw wasn't real. And the number of remote
viewers who've seen this is really overwhelming. And as I pointed out in, in our previous spaces,
historically clairvoyants have always seen that information going all the way back to the beginning.
So it's not even like a new idea. It's, you know, we can trace it back to at least,
you know, around the time of Christ, probably back to 578 BC.
Yeah. It's, uh, it's unfortunate, but I think that's what the, oh yeah. So let's wrap it up, dude.
Um, it's, uh, it's, it's a shame that, uh, you know, whoever these people are running the simulation,
uh, I guess, have us in such chaos. Um, you know, I'm almost, I'm laying here thinking,
you know, they have 200,000 human brain cells playing doom. I mean, what a game to play. You know,
you're running down hallways being chased and shooting creatures and demons. Like,
you know, let's, let's play a game. Let's all collectively play a game. That's happy,
you know, uh, sunshine.
We created these lives, right? I didn't, but they created those lives and they put them in hell.
Basically. Yes. That's what I'm getting at.
Yeah. And that, that would be my argument about our lives and our reality. So the thing about this is,
um, okay. I'm not making, I am not making a statement about what we're talking about related
to this, right? Like you'd have to draw your own conclusions. I don't know what will happen,
but when we talk about like, what is, what's predicted to happen in April, that would be of,
uh, right. So we have this whole thing where it's not just Chris Bledsoe. Other streams through
the years have made similar predictions and astral, the, the, the, the explanation that he received
for the event that's supposed to happen this year that he believed was going to happen in April,
which is a new knowledge entering the world. Okay. That was the, the, uh, this, this event will
happen in a new knowledge lens of the world. So his astrology was all jumbled up. Like he didn't know
the right color for Regulus. He said, Regulus was a red star. Regulus is a blue star. There are three
stars there actually. None of them are red. He said, Regulus would, would rise through the pause
of the Sphinx in an Easter. It doesn't until October. So, um, like he just listed off a bunch of,
uh, it, it, I spent, I didn't pay any attention. I don't pay any attention to those people, but
other people I talked to do. And so I try to answer their questions. So I spent some time trying to
figure out what the hell happened to Chris Bledsoe. The remote viewers all say he did experience
something. He had an NHI experience. So I tried to figure out like, what is he saying with this
jumbled up astrology? And I found that, um, in Vedic astrology, the period of time from the 29th of
March through April is, um, a, it's part of a lunar mansion, right? The, the, the, the south node,
K2 it's called in Vedic. It's an imaginary point. It's one of the imaginary points that we use in
astrology. We call it the south node. They call it Ketu. Um, they, they believe it's an invisible
planet. We, we, we know it's just like a hypothetical point in space, but it, it goes through a, a, a
point on the Zodiac that is ruled by Regulus during this period. So Bledsoe didn't understand that,
but there is actually a reason why they would associate Regulus with this period. Just
what he said didn't make any sense. And then Mars, right? Orthodox Easter is the 12th.
And so between regular Easter and Orthodox Easter, that's when Mars enters, uh, Aries. And, um, on, um,
the night of Good Friday, Orthodox Good Friday is when, uh, Mars will cross that point that we were
talking about earlier, zero degrees Aries with that conjunction happened. So, and that's supposed to be
like, that's going to be, uh, uh, uh, uh, something's going to happen. So another thing that, that
relates to Neptune and Saturn is sort of a dispensation of knowledge. It is like new religions,
new religious teachings. Okay. Uh, occur during that period of time. So I don't think the lady is
benevolent, um, like that he reported like this, this NHI interaction, uh, and he predicted the
orbs were going to show up once the war with Iran started. And there are orbs all over the place,
apparently in the Middle East right now, right? They're being reported in the world press. So it
turns out his prediction was right. Um, so what's going on with this, this lady thing, right? Like,
like, so a new knowledge is being misinterpreted because it's, it's being said from a mystical
standpoint, right? And we're talking about a, a Neptune Saturn conjunction. So we're talking about
Gnosis, a new Gnosis, which means knowledge in Greek. We're not talking about like a new
technical document. We're not talking about a book. We're talking about a note, a new Gnosis. So a new,
you could say a new age of Gnosis. You can talk about an age related to psychic ability being used
to explain or probe reality. Like that fits completely with that. And now here's the, the kicker,
right? So when, um, when the few, uh, remote viewers who have seen outside of the reality, um,
overlay in this thought exercise, this hypothetical fictional products, when they have looked outside
of it, uh, and tried to identify what was going on to create this, one of them came back and said,
uh, the problem that they have is for some reason, women stopped being born.
So what they're saying is that this, this, this, this whole thing was started because
they don't have any women. Now I know that sounds strange, but go back to the fallen angels. Why did
the angels fall from heaven to marry human wives? Because they didn't have any women. That's in,
that's in the book of Enoch. It goes back 2000 years. And, uh, what did this whole thing with this,
um, is the, the lady, the return of the divine feminine to whom?
Is it the return of the divine feminine to America? Is it the return of the divine feminine to earth?
Or are we talking about something that's related to the reality overlay? The purpose of the reality
overlay, the purpose of this emergence? Well, we, what, what they, these NHI or whatever the hell
they are, or these hallucinations or whatever it is referred to as the return of the divine feminine,
could that be related to the return of the actual feminine in this, like, what was that movie with
Clive Owens, like city of man or something? It's like, oh, children, children, children of man,
yeah, this external children of men dystopia that people are seeing related to the existence of this, um,
reality overlay. That's like, that's sort of a weird series of connections because when Chris Bledsoe started
making a, first of all, like when the book of Enoch was written, no one knew anything about us.
When Chris Bledsoe started making his predictions, right? No one knew anything about the remote viewing
data related to external. So these are three completely separate data points that are all in alignment
in a very strange way. I'm not saying that that that's, that's conclusive proof of anything. Again,
this is just a thought exercise. I'm saying it's fucking weird. Right. And so that is all supposedly
tied into whatever is supposed to happen, uh, this year, uh, possibly next month, um, is the return
of this gnosis. And I don't know, um, you know, I used to hope this was my secret hope that the guys
with, um, that, that some of the remote viewers would get their shit together, both the ones that I knew,
but all of the other remote viewers who are concealing this information, because they all
are right. And we're talking dozens, if not more than dozens who've had this, this, the same session
data without knowing what they were getting into, without having any personal knowledge of the history
of Gnosticism, esoteric science, anything like that. More viewers, like generally very average Americans
who don't know anything about that stuff, right. Other than what they see in sessions. So I,
I was hopeful secretly this whole time that like some of them would come forward and they would put
out a book or something. And that was what my hope was. Uh, it turns out that's not happening,
but maybe, maybe some of them are working on one that I don't know about. Uh, but that would be one
way that could, that could play out. Um, but certainly even if it's not related to this gnosis,
that's what the prediction is. And that prediction, the return of a new knowledge, the return of a new
gnosis, right. To, to mankind or the return of gnosis to mankind is completely 100% in align alignment
with the concept of Saturn conjunct Neptune at zero degrees. It really is all fits together. And it's so
tightly that if nothing happens at all, I'm going to be like, wow, that's, that's just the craziest,
that would be the craziest story of all. Like potentially being old someday and saying,
you'll never going to believe this weird series of events that just didn't amount to anything.
Or maybe something will. Yeah, sure. And in a way though, um, I would almost hope it leads to nothing
because then that means we're still here. And, uh, I, I guess, but you, you know, you'd want things to
change for the better, but, um, I believe, yeah, I really believe. Okay. I know when we're getting,
uh, cause I'm getting to cat time too. Uh, more, I, I seriously believe. Uh, so one thing that you,
you learn when you say astrology is, um, there's evolutionary aspect, it's called evolutionary
astrology, but you can, you can trace people's relationships through their, if you believe
reincarnation, through their reincarnations. So you can see, uh, by comparing astrological charts,
whether people knew each other prior to this life or not, and how they knew each other prior to this
life. If they did, were they mother and child? Were they, uh, in a relationship? Were they co-workers?
Were they revolutionaries together? You can see that in an astrological chart or when comparing
their astrological charts. Uh, I think that those of us who like fall is like, for instance, uh,
Morgan and I had one of those connections. Uh, and I don't mean that in a way, like, um,
you know, I'm not both Morgan and I like women. Right. And there's nothing wrong with not liking
women, but it was nothing. I'm not saying like, um, if you say I had a connection with this person,
like in our time, everyone just sort of like, you know, giggles, but I believe that those of us who
are open to this information and aware of this information, I believe many, if not all of us
came into this life for that purpose, maybe for other purposes. But if you talk about like having,
you know, pre-life contracts, whatever, they use all those new age information, who knows,
but I think that that's true to an extent. And I think that if we weren't
different or here for different reasons, we would also be incapable of accepting the information the same
way everyone else is. I do believe that. So, uh, yeah, sure. It, it might, it might actually just
boil down to, we, uh, might share some of the same brain cells in the Petri dish, so to say.
Correct. Well, isn't that, I don't know how familiar you are with, um, with new age thinking,
right? But that's one of the ideas the new agers have had is that, uh, you know, you're not here
as one person, you're here as 36 people. Sure. Yeah. Yeah. Right. We could each be a box.
I'll tell you something else, Shane, before we go. Yeah. Those boxes show up, dude. Those boxes show
up in the RV, black boxes related to, they show up in the RV and they show up in, um, alien abductions.
They show up in alien abduction encounters. Uh, the aliens have black boxes. They put people's souls
into after the people have passed away. Um, it's, there's been a lot of people, but it's definitely
something that people have experienced. They've reported the boxes. They've reported, uh, being
put into the boxes. You've probably heard it as called the, um, black cube of Saturn, that whole
thing. Exactly. I was just thinking that. Yeah. And your karma is stored in those boxes.
Right. So like, I, I think this, we can actually trace the actual devices. Like I, I'm telling you,
like this is, this is all coming together. And until now, no one understood how to put it together.
But once you have that master key, like it, it all sort of, it's very, if I wrote this as a book,
it would be an uncomfortable book, but it would be a very coherent book.
All right. I have to go. Um, thank you everyone for staying. I know it's
Thank you so much at the end. And, uh, you know, I, I offended like half a dozen people or a dozen
people, but, uh, well, I'm saying, I'm saying this for everyone else, right? Like, and so thank you
very much for being here. Melissa, you all have been to every one of mine. Thank you. And, um,
I was just about to say thank you to the woman who just left, uh, but she peaced out first, Danny.
Thank you. Um, and I hope you guys have a great night and, uh, I will be here Thursday for 200 griefers.
If anyone has any interest, um, in that subject, maybe I'll change it. If no one, like we already
went over it now, but, um, I don't know, maybe I won't, I think why not talk about it. Right.
So sure. I mean, it's interesting nonetheless.
I think so. Yeah. And I, you know, I, I got a, yeah, I got a good, uh, little poster for it
and everything already set up. All right. Uh, Barkley, good doc. Thank you very much for coming.
Uh, there'll be 15 seconds before a silence before it disconnects.
Good night, JT. Good night.
Thank you.